House Republicans to vote on Bill
abolishing IRS eliminating income tax I
know it's not going to happen but it's
just so funny apparently it was part of
the deal they were telling Kevin
McCarthy if you want our votes you have
to let us vote to abolish the IRS and he
had to agree I'm having a good time here
we got a bunch of crazy news Republicans
have stepped into Congress and they're
going ham an investigation into Joe
Biden they say they're going to be
releasing footage from January 6. we'll
see if that actually happens they're
booting several Democrats off of their
committees and boy are those Democrats
pissed off they're saying we're supposed
to you know put forward as the minority
party our picks for these committees why
is Kevin McCarthy kicking us off and he
says because Nancy Pelosi played that
game game because she booted Marjorie
Taylor green and gosar and if that's the
Congress she wants it's the Congress she
gets now a lot of this as I mentioned in
my earlier segment it's all symbolic you
know they're not going to abolish the
IRS but one can dream right it would be
just so funny but ultimately what ends
up happening is they force the Democrats
to vote in favor of the IRS that's going
to be uh a lot in the me more so we got
to talk about all that but before we do
my friends head over to
surfinginternetsafe.com and get virtual
Shield a virtual private Network sponsor
in the show thank you so much virtual
Shield the virtual private network
service helps keep you safe as you
browse the internet so it stops
government hackers roads random hackers
it stops your isps from tracking your
data go to Virtual uh I'm sorry go to
surfinginternetsafe.com and you will get
what do they got here 78 off I think
they're doing this time 8.33 cents per
month they say that their VPN service is
compatible with all devices it allows
you to browse the web safely security
and anonymously using their Global
Network of servers and private IPS it
lets you browse the web completely
anonymously so big name isps and other
third parties will not be able to
Monitor and sell your internet activity
your traffic will be routed through
their secure and encrypted servers
meanings meaning it will bypass any
restrictions or censorship or blocks on
your internet you get a fast reliable
secure and always available available
Network completely free for 30 days for
Mac Windows iPhone iPad Android or
Chrome you've got your personal your
family your business plans available
family plan gets your 15 devices
business plan gets you as many as your
as many employees as you need and
they'll completely encrypt your Wi-Fi as
well even hide your IP address so again
head over to surfing internet safe pick
up virtual Shield they're our first
sponsor we're eternally grateful that
they're helping support the show as long
as they have been and if you want to
take your privacy seriously
surfinginternetsafe.com but don't forget
head over to timcast.com become a member
clicking that little join us button
right there on the left
and you'll get access to exclusive
uncensored members only segments of this
show we're going to have one of those up
for you tonight at around 11 p.m and I
want to say the other thing you do by
becoming a member is you support the
cultural movement we've got a coffee
shop in the works a skate shop in the
works one big building games coffee
hangout Etc we want to be we want to
launch a ton of coffee shops around the
country in the in this coming year and
it's going to be a task and that means
we've uh we've got to allocate resources
towards doing it with your support we
will be able to outside of all the shows
we're creating and I'll tell you what
else we're going to do
this Saturday DC's Freedom Plaza I will
go skate I will be there come hang out
and skate no special event no tents no
no speakers nothing just quite literally
I will be there skating and I would like
you to show up and uh maybe we'll be
able to say what's up maybe it'll get
too crowded I don't know for sure but
the point is we're going to assert
ourselves and these ourselves in these
cultural spaces so I hope to see you
there a lot of people are saying what's
going to be dangerous Tim it's going to
be dangerous I'm like okay well that may
be the case but uh these people can't
tell me how I live my life I'm gonna go
skate where I want to skate and do what
I want to do and I hope to see you there
so smash that like button subscribe to
this channel share the show with your
friends joining us tonight to talk about
this and so much more is Taylor Hansen
thanks for having me Tim who are you uh
Taylor Hansen as he said I'm an
independent journalist I covered the
2020 Summer of Love riots are mostly
peaceful uh protest one could say I was
there on January 6th I documented the
death of Ashley Babbitt in the name of
the shooter as Michael bird and most
notably recently I have been uncovering
and going undercover in all ages or
child-friendly drag shows
right on for thanks for joining us and
we also have Phil Labonte returning
what's up
what's
up
you can book some eardrums you can do
better than that come on yeah that was
like a queef I tell you what I I
appreciate that vote of confidence from
you Luke I really do hi everybody I am
Phil I sing for a band called All That
Remains uh we are a heavy metal band uh
and we've been playing metal and scream
for a long time and I am happy to be
here tonight and uh
and I'm gonna be here uh a lot more
that's right if uh if that's cool to
talk about now I guess oh yeah yeah I'm
going to be joining the uh Tim cast crew
and uh so I'll be around I'm not gonna
be here every night but all you're gonna
see my face a whole bunch and I'll be
loud and it'll be fun absolutely and uh
you're gonna be here on Saturday right I
am going to be in in DC on Saturday too
so we're gonna grab an acoustic yeah and
just please go hang out in the plaza and
just jam out sing some songs skate and
uh anybody wants to come hang out you
know just come on what's up come say
what's up
we got Luke you're coming I'm going uh
more about that later but anyway today I
decided to wear my Bold and Beautiful
depiction of an FBI agent stomping out a
domestic terrorist Lady Liberty uh buy
this shirt please so I could help fix my
front door after I get raided by the FBI
on the best politicalshirts.com because
you guys do that that's the best way to
support me here while I am still here
thank you again so much for having me I
all great news I'm glad you're here Phil
this is really cool man and um we were
talking earlier about at the whole
Ashley bat we got to go into it on the
show talk about your experience in the
capital on the sixth that was nuts yeah
let's roll forward and come back around
into this absolutely search tell to me
hey what's up guys I'm adserve.com I'm
ready for this uh fun conversation we're
gonna have glad to see back Phil pleased
to meet you Taylor Let's Get It Started
all right here's the first story from
Fox News House Republicans to vote on
Bill abolishing IRS eliminating income
tax vote on abolishing IR IRS part of
deal between speaker McCarthy and the
house Freedom caucus
Fox News digital has learned the house
will be voting on a Georgia Republican
rep buddy Carter's reintroduced fair tax
act that aims to reel in the IRS and
remove the national income tax as well
as other taxes and replace them with a
single consumption tax the vote in the
bill was made as part of the deal
between house Speaker Kevin McCarthy and
members of the House Freedom caucus and
was pushed forward in his quest for the
gavel last week okay full stop
the failures of the GOP in this midterm
are the greatest gift to all of us you
know why Kevin McCarthy thought he would
not need to negotiate with the freedom
caucus members because they were going
to have a red wave so pronounced the 20
or so vote holdouts would have been
completely irrelevant and then because
the GOP underperformed he had to go
crawling to members of the freedom
caucus as well as people like you know
it's like Matt Gates lawnmower and then
say okay fine what do you want and now
we get something as bold as abolishing
the IRS vote on the house floor it's not
going to happen the Senate will reject
it but I want you all to understand when
the Democrats vote to support the IRS
when the Democrats they've already voted
to defend the 87 000 IRS agents when
you're having dinner with your family
and your aunt Aetna is like well the
Republicans they're eviling you but yeah
you know I hear you but man the
Democrats voted to defend the IRS get
your Democrat relatives to defend the
IRS in front of everybody and see how
well that goes the IRS is actually a
good thing Tim
no no no no no I I actually agree with
you thank you so much for bringing this
up I mean the IRS they're pretty much
like those little uh you know uh gnomes
but but instead of uh also like those
little Christmas elves but instead of
leaving stuff they just take stuff for
themselves and without them who's going
to finance the next Epstein Island right
who's going to make sure that the
special interests get all their money
who's gonna make sure that corn seed
oils are subsidized right it has to be
the IRS agents they're they're very Bold
and Beautiful Brave members of the
government that of course are not
working for a corrupted hijacked
government that of course is spending
our money and wasting it on special
interests so uh yeah we got to protect
the IRS guys personally I love being
rated for a 600 transactions on them I'm
looking forward to it well this is
what's gonna happen you're gonna let her
in the mail it's going to say you owe 73
and you're going to be like what what do
I owe 73 dollars for this is ridiculous
and they're going to have your list of
transactions they're going to say well
we think that this transaction was
income and you're like that was me
moving like I moved money from my
checking account to my venmo that's not
new money nah looks like new money to US
73 good luck you gonna call a lawyer
lawyer's gonna be allowed for 1 thousand
dollars I'll send a letter that will get
that 73 you're gonna be like strongly
worded it'll get the 73 they'll knock it
down by about like 50 that's right you
have to pay like you know 38 or whatever
I guess if you're rich and you're like
it's the thought that counts it's the
principle of things but for the average
person you're gonna be gutted so we're
getting a lot of this I don't know
symbolic victories it's all symbolic and
it's it's all really lame they're like
there is value in like the meme factor I
suppose in like the culture war or for
talking points but there's no substance
there it's all just you know feels good
it does feel good it's fun I mean like I
said I love to meme I like cyber
bullying people in Washington as much as
the next libertarian you know but when
it comes to good it does but there's no
there's no there's no there there
there's no substance yeah you know that
this the Senate's gonna turn it down
it's not going to happen but it's good
to get the Democrats to say we like the
IRS yeah I I love hearing abolish the
IRS but don't tease me with a good time
without letting me finish here come on
guys seriously this is this is not right
you know what it's still not clear is if
they actually did something but we know
that the uniparty can't have that yes I
so so we have these symbolic gestures
that amount to nothing they're cute
won't change anything and uh of course
they're they're patting themselves on
the back look guys we did this I mean
you're pathetic I don't seriously
absolutely pathetic I don't want to
shoot the process in the foot
unnecessarily because it hasn't gone to
the Senate yet and it may get passed
through the Senate even if it does then
could Biden veto it I think Biden could
yeah they pass the inflation reduction
act with which major support from the
Republicans you think they're going to
pass a bill that's going to ban the IRS
well they're supposed I wish they should
they should at least get rid of all
those tens of thousands of new agents
that are going to be hounding poor
people and the latest reports that are
coming out in 2022 the IRS
overwhelmingly went after and targeted
poor people more than they did people
with significant amount of income
they're doing this in order to of course
keep people in line as they literally
print money out of thin air this is such
a just a dish with respectful slap in
the face to anyone paying attention here
as our economy is being deliberately
destroyed in order to push a great reset
we're here today and there's no going
back from this we have this little
symbolic gesture it's nothing I I do
enjoy the optimism though I'm kind of
getting the feeling that Luke doesn't
like the government just a little just a
tiny yeah we we were at Turning Point
USA and Luke I think was saying defund
the IRS or abolish the IRS and all these
young Republicans were like yeah and now
you see the Republican leadership in the
house proposing that we do it so like
not the leadership they didn't want to
do this well we got they got the
leadership to do it they got Kevin
McCarthy to do it so you know they are
supposed to represent the will of the
people regardless and so maybe the will
of the people is Shifting and people are
listening to that I put a poll in the
chat abolish the IRS four percent said
no yeah I want to know who these four
percent are yeah
I don't think they're illiterate people
I don't think you can fix politics with
politics that's the problem I'm at the
four percent is the people that couldn't
read the poll yeah they accidentally hit
the wrong button you know oh it's it's
shifting though now it went three or
four so it's like as more votes come in
there's about 2 700 it's people are
saying yesterday they voted to defund
the 87 000 agents and then today they
voted to completely abolish the entire
program no they're going to okay so they
voted to get rid of the 87 000 agents
and the Democrats all voted in favor of
these agents no but that does matter I
mean we're not it's not going to go
anywhere the Senate's gonna reject it
but seriously that's going to be in
every political ad in 2024 every
commercial is going to be like rocana
voted to support 87 000 new IRS agents
to Target your small bank account it's
it's it every single One's Gonna say no
way I think it's gonna I mean we're too
far away especially when it comes to
people's attention especially when it
comes to the upcoming election there's
no way they're going to remember this
um I I just don't see it personally
myself and you know the Democrats
wanting more government and more IRS
agents what a shocker even if they do
run ads though I mean you have these
people on the left right now I mean
they're going to cheer for it anyway
they're going to say okay yeah that's
that's the virtuous thing to do we
should tax these people we should tax
the rich that's what it's going to get
to redistribute the wealth from people
they're just hot and bothered when they
hear that they're gonna start saying
well it's a very important service
provided to to maintain our government I
mean we don't we're not anarchists
democracy
their weapons Luke did you hear that
what someone said we're not anarchists
but of course they're they're all status
commies
in the parks department don't get me
started on that uh but but seriously
Ukraine has to get their money right yes
why do you like dislike the parks
department because it pisses me off the
way that they run and operate is
absolutely nonsensical it's a park it
doesn't need bureaucracy it doesn't need
government and for the government to
intervene especially in places like New
York City because I lived in New York
City I loved New York City And Then
There came the parks department that
literally started to arrest people give
people summonses and put them in court
because they dared to walk through a
park at a certain time that they that
the state the parks department didn't
like that yeah that that to me is
absolutely insane Draconian and and just
top-tier communism
my blood pressure's gonna go upstairs
the parks because otherwise that's
they're hubs for crime like like at
night people wait wait until you learn
about poor neighborhoods Ian like and
they all got to keep them clean to the
parks and you got to pay people to go do
that but how much funding do they really
need I don't know not I wouldn't think a
lot but I could be wrong
in like the year 1800s you know there's
no income tax yeah they did fine and
there was a lot of prosperity and there
was of course what do you mean there was
a lot of killing of Native Americans in
the 1800s like a lot of just but also
before 1913 right before the Federal
Reserve was enacted before there was the
creature from Jekyll Island before there
was this larger kind of income tax
levied against everyone else how did the
government run
pretty well on a limited basis and
private business and private Enterprise
was allowed to prosper and it did and
the roads were built magically and they
were still there magically it's not
magic it's of course Common Sense
whenever you have the government taken
away from people you have them depriving
them of any kind of prosperity of any
kind of Liberty of any kind of freedom
and if you think the government has a
duty to redistribute wealth you're an
absolute lunatic who is obviously just
facilitating the larger transfer of
wealth of your money to of course the
big Banks the big corporations that
truly do call the shots at government
and the most powerful people are only
enriched by more government look that's
racist I don't give a damn what it is
it's the truth and I'm speaking my
truths here because because can you see
it well make a counter argument how long
until they uh write an article saying
Republicans effort to abolish the IRS is
rooted in white supremacy I guarantee it
exists it'll be soon 100 it exists
because they probably wrote it about
Libertarians already it probably already
yeah it's probably already you just gave
them great headline idea so next week I
would say Media Matters get on it you
write that thing I'm a person of color
so they can't make that argument
personally I'm trans racial you can be
transgender actually so I think I found
I think about the opposite how federal
tax law hurts black Americans thank you
which is probably no so actually the IRS
is racist yes the tax codes racial
disparities well we got to get rid of
all that yes to counter your argument a
little bit Luke is that I think a lot of
the things like the power Monopoly
you're talking about could happen in the
private sector as well and so you need
some form of government to protect the
Common Man from
and uh mafias and things until you have
another Mafia make up to fight the
mafias you have less Mafia technically
the mafia was created and made as
powerful as they are because of the the
prohibition because of the Banning of
alcohol which was a stupid idea because
the government going around and
poisoning people just to prove a larger
Point here this is what led mafias to be
as powerful as they are you look at a
lot of the cartels they wouldn't exist
if it wasn't for the War on Drugs the
biggest Mafia of all the government
facilitating this larger kind of Mafia
growth also NASCAR
well without prohibition you don't get
NASCAR what happens is that's true this
government that's actually true the
NASCAR got started because dudes were
souping up their cars to get away from
the cops when they were when they were
running shine oh yeah yeah so you don't
get nasty so what you're saying is if
there was no government
if there wasn't government maybe the
government is
yeah
yeah because they're still Indie and
NASCAR only turns left it's the laziest
racing there's Indy 500 racing that
where they turn left and right NASCAR's
just left I'm sorry Mark I know you love
it but it's just left turns it's left
turns and crashes that's all anyone
cares about
I like Indy 500 that sounds fun Indy 500
right you say they turn right and left
right and left right both wow but the
point I'm trying to make is that rather
than just demonize quote the government
just acknowledge that our federal
government's way too big it's too
influential in people's lives it needs
to be reduced in size not that there
should never be any government ever
because I think some government is
extremely valuable in protecting common
people from corporations and things
how dare you that's what police forces
is like a local government all the all
the big monopolies right now are as
powerful as they are abuse so much power
and and get away with so much big Pfizer
big agriculture all those companies get
away with it because of their
connections and manipulating with
government Ian's saying like a fire
department is good he's not saying no no
he's saying the government needs to be
there to keep the corporations in check
right but I'm saying the government is
there to make the corporations Monopoly
you're you're arguing against the
current iteration of government which is
massive power structures Ian's basically
saying there is some degree of
government that's fine
we don't need the bureaucracy that
supports big big farm and all that we
don't need police departments or fire
departments not gonna be private but we
do need at least one thing of parks
department oh yeah
most important one hands down yeah
nothing else the government literally
just becomes a guy in a park being like
you can't come in have you been talking
to Mike cernovich about it he just had a
revelation about how awesome the US
parks are no he's like everyone should
the US parks are beautiful and they're
awesome yeah and they should be
preserved obviously but you could do
that independently you could do that
privately you don't need a parks
department arresting people for walking
in nature or camping or camping that
that to me is one of the biggest
ridiculous ideas that they could they
could micromanage you being in nature
privatization of land and and property
and stuff like that does preserve
property if you want to save endangered
species the best thing you can do is
have someone that has the resources get
a bunch of them on their private land so
no one can hunt them and they can take
care of them and then that will save the
species there's tons of species that
have been saved throughout the whole
world because of privatization same
thing down in uh in in Africa there's a
lot of a lot of yeah there's a lot of
people that uh
um privatize the land for safaris and
stuff and people think or and I'm not
sure if so far is the right word because
it's not a hunt where it's just like
sightseeing that they do they can see
wild animals and I probably use the
wrong turns good but but it but what it
does is it preserves the land and it
preserves the animals because there's a
financial incentive to preserve the land
and preserve the animals so people can
see them you know it's like there's
there's a way to monetize things in a
positive way they're like you can
absolutely use the incentive of profit
to have good results that is one of the
most obvious things living in modern
society it's it's almost it's so obvious
that people don't see it it's so
prevalent that people don't see it but
privatization is generally a good thing
now it's not to say that there aren't
problems or can't be problems but
privatization versus government it's
almost always better for privatization
because at the very least you're not
adding
you're not adding legal violence yes
thank you let's jump to this next
question here we got this uh tweet from
rep Eric swalwell he's just breaking rep
Byron Donalds admits on the readout that
McCarthy is kicking me Adam Schiff and
ilhan off our committees purely out of
Vengeance yes I'm sure it's out of
engines not the fact that you slept at
the Chinese spy and she married her
brother right yeah that's thanks okay
fair point but I'll accept the Vengeance
yeah yeah I'm here for it it feels good
either one is fine with me man you're a
piece of garbage it's entertaining to
see him complains the amount of
entitlements
it's our counselor it's our what do they
call it committee whatever dude it's the
American people's committee whatever
prevents him from dropping nukes on
Americans that don't turn in their
AR-15s I'm fine we're having sex with
more Chinese spies Fang Fang had to work
really hard okay this is this is the she
really loses here more than anyone else
here how did this happen Eric swallows
on the what a house intelligence
committee and he's dating a Chinese spy
who's harvesting intelligence
is it confirmed that she was withdraw
drawing extracting info from the guy do
you know I'm not entirely sure if it's
confirmed I mean but he was dating and
having sexual relations with the Chinese
spy so I can only imagine that I mean
and Adam Schiff lied all the time of the
intelligence and actually Adam's shift
should be removed from office just
because the of the the it's because of
his neck just because he was going maybe
um just because he went to he was trying
to get people banned from Twitter he was
he was sending emails to Twitter
infringe on people's first minute right
he released a private Citizen's phone
records yeah disgusting absolutely
disgusting creepy he got a journalist
actually suspended and permanently
banned off of Twitter well the guy that
works for Real Clear investigations
right on like it's unconscionable that
people that politicians behave like that
and it's extremely disheartening that
we're such a tribal Society right now
that we can't all say okay that's a
violation of liberal principles and
we're you can't be in a position of
power anymore that should be something
that all all Americans say but that's
not happening anymore yeah oh the the
mess the mistake is that they say
Twitter's a private company so if I
walked into the Apple headquarters and I
started screaming they could kick me out
because it's a private company but it's
a different kind of Private Structure in
that it's a social network no it's not
because Adam Schiff is a rep as a as a
representative of the government getting
a hold of Twitter saying ban this person
that is prohibited by the First
Amendment so could could the government
cannot tell an intermediary to violate
someone's rights but could they say hey
Tim Cook at Apple don't let Ian Crossing
into the Apple headquarters could Adam
Schiff do that and then no Tim Cook's
like oh no you can't no because it's a
violation of your rights to go into the
Apple headquarters you you know they
they don't have the right
to tell someone else to violate your
right you have the right to move you
have the right to exchange in or to
engage in in Commerce the rights that an
individual has are infinite you have the
right to get up and leave you have the
right to the bathroom these are all
rights that you have you have the
because you're a free person so if Tim
Cook doesn't have a problem with you
going into his business and and you
don't have a problem and the government
says Tim Cook don't let that guy in your
in your business the government's saying
that what applies significant pressure
because it's the government the
government has the Monopoly on violence
so if they say that to Tim Cook and Tim
Cook says well you know I want him to
come in and buy stuff but the government
said I can't so I don't I can't let you
in Ian that's the government using their
influence on Tim Cook Tim Cook to
violate your rights and that is
expressly prohibited I don't know the
court the the court cases but I know
that the the Supreme Court has found
that the government cannot do those kind
of the government can't use the private
sector as a means to suppress your
rights but do I have a right to go into
the Apple headquarters I don't think
that's it if Tim Cook doesn't want you
to or Tim you do have a right if if uh
building like the Apple Store well she's
the Apple headquarters if uh lose the
Apple Store as an example if it's open
to the public you do so like any private
company any little shop on Main Street
anything that anything that's a public
accommodation that allows people to
enter you can enter and they can give
you a warning to leave then they can
call the police the police give you a
warning then the police can remove you
or arrest you but if a corporation is
running a public-facing publicly
available business you have a right to
enter that business
yeah and then they have a right to tell
you to leave if you remember a couple
years ago I was even saying these are
not private companies they're they're
working colluding together we're at
government working on the beheads of
government implementing a lot of their
policies that the government wants them
to implement and they parade themselves
around like look we're a private entity
we're a private business we could do
what we want no your tax dollars are
literally being used for FBI agents to
sit on social media to say you cannot
have speech here you cannot express your
opinion here and also when you look at
the the start of all of a lot of these
companies they they started with
connections not only to the government
but there was a lot of Grants there was
a lot of incentives that that allowed
them to become as powerful as they are
right now where they have a sort of
Monopoly on on the industry and they
dominate everyone where competitors
can't even compete with them because of
the unfair Advantage the government gave
them during the beginning of their start
uh which I think is important to note
here which also tells me this is nothing
to do with any private entity here this
is this is Aussie public one let's talk
about the yeah
the elephant in the room
the Civil War that collapsed and has
myocarditis if if we're entering this
period where in Congress they're doing a
Tit for Tat Vengeance that Nancy Pelosi
boots people off committees because she
doesn't like them so then McCarthy comes
in and Boots people off committees
because he's like okay this game we're
gonna play I mean we're heading to a
point where elections are determined by
who can collect the most abouts possible
not who actually has the best ideas
ballot Harvest and get the biggest
number and you're good to go and uh
Power will be wielded exclusively by
each side for their own benefit I don't
I I would I would expect the Republicans
to do exactly this I expect the
Republicans to impeach Joe Biden but of
course the Democrats started it and of
course they're not going to stop so if
we're at this point and the bifurcation
just keeps going where do we end up
the biggest split you've ever seen I
mean I think we're already at the point
where the country is divided like we've
never seen before but it's just going to
keep going and keep going but I've
always said that the right because the
right's always been the party of
defensive so it's nice to actually it's
refreshing to see that they're actually
taking the offensive at least somewhat
nowadays but I mean it's like Saul
Alinsky the left literally operates off
of Rules for Radicals I mean that's how
they play you blame others of what
you're guilty of I mean the whole nine
yards so now that the ride is actually
doing it it's just going to keep going
and keep going until something finally
breaks and this is where I will agree
you know eventual Civil War or whatever
you want to word it as did you always
think that no no I mean over time I mean
one of the reasons why I got into the
industry was because I saw that the the
Republicans were just playing defensive
over and over again I was like okay we
need to fix this I mean I was an
activist before a journalist so I
painted baby lives matter murals outside
of abortion clinics pissed a lot of
people off but it was like a spin-off of
BLM right I was like they're doing it
I'll do it push back
um and then you know over time as I
became more radicalized or more rational
is what I would say uh I mean it just
kind of evolved my thought process and
now here we are I would agree that if if
it continues on the path that it's going
without intercession that we would see
some sort of physical conflict I mean
we've already seen physical conflict I
mean I mean you were right there when
Ashley Babbitt got shot yeah I mean
that's as physical as it gets I mean
that was government sanctioned murder I
mean the government's going to murder
people on National Television over and
over again and nobody says a thing I
mean there's no repercussions for it
they literally dropped all charges they
didn't actually investigate Michael bird
after the shooting I mean they did a
faux investigation and said oh yeah he's
cleared all the police violence that
took place on January 6 is cleared so
it's like how far can you continue to go
how how much government sanctioned
murder because that's what it was can
you actually tolerate until something
finally breaks did that change you
watching her get shot oh absolutely I
mean I think about it every single day
and I've been thankful to you know
really get close with her family her
family is like my family now Aaron
Babbitt Mickey they're absolutely
amazing people it's not what the media
says you know Ashley Babbitt wasn't some
you know disorganized terrorist that
wanted to go and take down the
government she was actually trying to
stop people within that room she punched
Zachary llama in the face and pulled him
backwards and then she went through the
window to try and stop this crowd but
you never hear about that wow he also
said that there were surveillance
footage in the capital showing the
incident that also can't be found yep
and then uh you almost told us something
about uh people being near her not being
prosecuted as well can you get into any
of this stuff yeah I can get into it all
um so the people that actually breach
the west side of the Capitol none of
them have been prosecuted I mean the
ones that actually they're on video
throwing two by fours through the window
breaking these and then you know they
hop in and then open the doors from the
inside to allow everybody else in um you
know there's one in particular that I
can think of off the top of my head he's
wearing all red has a red hat on and
they actually somehow ended up very
conveniently in the room with Ashley
Babbitt right as she was being shot
right around Ashley Babbitt as this took
place and they were on just like Ray
apps they were put on the FBI Wanted
list and then immediately almost
immediately taken off right after but
you never hear about any of them
you know what's going on
one one could ask that and they probably
should but it's it's inconvenient to the
narrative and even if you do ask I mean
we've seen with what Ray Epps has uh
accomplished I mean he's literally on
video on January 5th multiple times
telling people to go into the capital uh
on multiple occasions and then January 6
doing the exact same thing I mean
there's even a video of him holding a
big uh Trump banner and actually pushing
it into police alongside other people
but you know Adam he's Adam kinsengers
and the committee's absolute darling and
they don't want to talk about and they
release the transcripts and it literally
says that hey I helped organize this and
he's on video doing so but you're not
allowed to talk about it and if you do
you're labeled conspiracy theories you
see there's transcripts of raps saying
that he helped organize January 6th yeah
I believe uh I don't know which
congressman that actually released it
originally um but I mean it's literally
in the transcripts that he is talking I
believe it's to his son I'm not 100 sure
on it but he organized it I mean he was
one of these organizers he said he
orchestrated it he is the person that I
followed to the Capitol while Trump was
speaking we arrived at the Capitol I
followed rayup's group I thought it was
suspicious he basically started rallying
people and saying hey 10 minutes we're
going to the Capitol we're going to the
Capitol and I'm sitting there like okay
this is really weird Trump supporters
going to the capital on Trump's very
last speech of the year his last speech
of his presidency to save America speech
is suspicious and you know I followed
them then the first barrier goes down
the second barrier goes down which
that's the famous video of Ray Epps you
know Whispering into Ryan samsel's ear
and then the barrier goes down
conveniently
um you know so he I was literally
alongside rayups he is the one that led
the first initial group on that west
side and breached those two barriers and
then something that isn't talked about
is after those first two barriers were
briefed you had about six officers
responsible for stopping hundreds of
thousands of people and there was a the
initial like you know I would call it
the riot zone or it was where the uh
they hold the inauguration every year
and they're the crowd of thousands of
people just started to form I mean
there's there's mothers there's children
people from all walks of life everyone's
just standing there I was already deep
in the crowd and it was peaceful for
about 20 to 30 minutes and then a
concussion grenade flies over my head
and explodes into the crowd and then it
just started to erupt so literally it
was a police riot
real quick we've got this from Colin
rugg he says Matt Gates says Republicans
will release 14 000 hours of January 6
tapes that were hidden by democrats
gates for the win once again
what could be on these tapes and do you
think it's going to happen
I think it has the potential of
happening but I don't I'm not super
positive just because of everything that
was supposed to come out hasn't come out
I mean I actually talked to Gates in a
Twitter space last night I asked him
about the same thing and you know he was
very positive about it he seemed you
know basically assured that these were
going to be released I mean I've seen a
good majority of this footage that's
been unreleased I wish I could talk
about it more but I can't but I mean
they've deleted footage they've scrubbed
through this so I mean even what you're
going to see if they do release this 14
000 hours of footage they're not going
to actually solve it they've deleted
some of it I mean they've said in public
statements that there was no video
camera where in the hallway where Ashley
Babbitt was shot there was multiple
video cameras I saw them myself multiple
congressmen can attest to actually
seeing the video cameras they're there
right now outside the speaker's lobby
but they don't want to release the other
angles of Ashley we have it being shot
because it shows Michael bird cowardly
hiding directly behind the barrier not
issuing a verbal warning not doing
anything and then stepping forward and
essentially executing Ashley Babbitt wow
what happened she climbed up on a like a
piece of furniture or something to get
through a window and they just thought
she was attacking them well so so what
what happened is you had multiple
officers standing basically guarding
those doors and me and Ashley were the
very first ones to get into that room
and I actually you know I offered
officer yetter that was his name a water
bottle because he was covered in capacin
powder and you know they said no you
know it's fine
um and Ashley Babbitt was literally
joking with the same officers that moved
out of the way of the barrier uh you
know minutes prior to her being shot and
that's the side of the story you never
hear but these cops the cert team which
Michael bird claims wasn't there that's
the reason why he shot Ashley Babbitt
they were there they were walking up the
stairs and for those of people that
don't know about the surf team it's
basically the Tactical Team for the
capital you can see it on video yeah you
can see it on video and that's you know
where people like see the thumbs up is
because they didn't realize when Michael
bird stepped forward and shot they
didn't realize if it was a friendly or
not that had fired that shot because it
was so unexpected I mean the cert team
was in the room with Babbitt and
everyone else and you actually right
before she is shot and killed and goes
to the window she grabs Zachary along
with her right hand and punches him in
the face knocking his glasses off and
Zachary Alon was the one that was
responsible for breaking all the
barriers out so she goes through the
window basically in order to try and
stop the crowd I mean she was on camera
and on audio basically yelling at these
officers to do their job multiple times
and then they didn't do their job they
shifted over certain team comes to
replace and now the video I mean the
windows are completely exposed so they
think people are saying she was going to
get up and turn around and yell at the
crowd like hey cut it out kind of thing
you gotta you got to think though I mean
she's 14-year Air Force veteran she's
been on multiple combat deployments she
knows what the rules of engagement are
right and you know is it easier to stop
an Angry Crowd or at least a few angry
people within the crowd when you're on
the same side of the barrier with her or
when you're on the opposite side of the
barrier and you know logic says on the
opposite side of the barrier you can
push people out the window you can stand
there you can guard the window or you
can at least grab that window pane
that's exposed and pull it back in have
they filed a wrongful death suit I'm not
sure if it's been officially filed but I
do know something is in the process and
it's also important to note that that
officer was acting extremely Reckless to
shoot an unarmed woman in it was in in
the neck or in the face it was in the
left anterior shoulder with you know
police officers behind her yeah and her
not directly or not being armed is is
absolutely something that that should
have been National headline news there
should have been some larger
accountability here but this officer was
investigated and not even held
accountable for for his crimes meanwhile
this was the same officer that left a
firearm in a public bathroom before yeah
in 2018 he left his loaded Glock in a uh
public bathroom and a civilian found it
in the capital and then you know his
quote is actually hilarious is he was
Lieutenant at the time he said I will
not be punished uh he says I will be
treated differently because of my rank
as Lieutenant so I mean if he actually
was de-ranked or actually punished with
how he was supposed to be in a proper
law enforcement scenario he wouldn't
have been there to shoot Ashley Babbitt
I mean it would have been somebody that
was leading the house security other
than Michael Burke I'm just thinking
about I mean you were there right and
you're you're a reporter or you're
covering what's going on how close how
close were you I mean was it were you in
danger yeah absolutely I mean not from
the uh the direct round I mean I was
closest to Michael bird out of anybody I
mean that's where you get like the hoax
of where oh he's on video giving her a
verbal warning but he didn't give her a
single verbal warning before he stepped
forward and shot her most people didn't
even realize that he was there it was so
loud in that room because you had a
crowd surge coming in from behind and
just overfilling and I mean like you had
John Sullivan which we all know about
John Sullivan uh he was right next to me
he has the angle of him actually
shooting Ashley and my angle is of
Ashley falling out the window and you
know he's screaming hey he's got a gun
because he's the only one that can see
Michael Burt and so I I remember I
started screaming it but you literally
can't hear from me to you and the
distance between me and Ashley was about
I mean for me and surge you know 10 15
feet and that's when I mean she went up
nobody even realized that there was a
gun there and he stepped forward and
executed her wow that's absolutely
absolutely just you know crazy insane
yeah I never you know in all my years
reporting I mean I cover the 2020 riots
um you know I've seen some pretty crazy
things you know the feet on fire Molotov
Clips all of those kinds of yeah we are
there I mean yeah in Portland
there was also that one in uh during the
DNC in Philadelphia yeah I think Mike
turnovich was down there too yeah and we
saw some fire yeah I mean I've seen some
really crazy things on the ground but I
mean I've never seen nothing will ever
compare to what I experienced on January
6 and of course it still lives with me
seeing an innocent woman basically get
murdered by the government in front of
me and then I remember that night really
just I mean I was in shock I remember
stumbling out of the capital not really
understanding what took place
um I went you know I went to the hotel
they basically did a little mini martial
law you couldn't even leave your hotel
afterwards and you know I was lucky
enough to stay with some of the Infowars
guys they brought me in because my hotel
was on the opposite side of the entire
town and you couldn't even walk outside
and I remember watching the TV and you
know I had licensed my footage but I
didn't feel right about making an actual
profit offer I gave it to these news
sources for like two dollars a clip
um and then you got John Sullivan
selling it for 85 000 which is absurd so
yeah he got criminally charged but and
then now he's perfectly fine living in
Utah doing the joints charges or what
I'm pretty sure they dropped the charges
I'm not 100 sure but there's it's
suspicious around him the FBI reached
out to me uh after the shooting and the
only thing they wanted to talk about
they didn't want to talk about literally
anything else other than John Sullivan
so that kind of puts it into perspective
they want to talk about their little uh
their little Patsy toy but you know the
night of I just watched on the news
they're using my footage and spinning a
completely different story on what
happened they didn't talk about how
Ashley was trying to de-escalate instead
she was called a violent terrorist and
insurrectionist so that's kind of when
it set in for me of like I'm in the
middle of a cover-up as Ray Epps is on
you know camera on January 5th saying
we're gonna storm the capital and on
multiple January 5th and then and then
people calling him a Fed people were
screaming fed fed fed and then he did
the same thing the next day yep he did
the same thing multiple times is on
camera multiple times on the sixth
organizing people at different points
saying we're going into the capital and
this is a man that still has not been
punished or even brought in for
questioning is that correct yeah well he
was brought in for questioning by the
January 6 committee which is convenient
because the committee I literally begged
them to tell my story I wanted to tell
my story to them reached out on multiple
accounts none of them wanted to talk to
me they refused which now we know why I
mean I saw something I wasn't supposed
to see on multiple occasions but I mean
then you got Ray Epps and he is
basically being paraded around as the
darling of the day by Adam kinsinger and
Liz Cheney saying oh no he did nothing
wrong even though he is on video
arguably doing more than almost
everybody that's actually been
prosecuted and sitting in a Cell right
that's crazy that raps thing is the most
agree like it's the one where I hear
about it I'm like oh I hear this guy
raps and then you see the video of him
and you hear his voice saying let's go
do this now like he's telling people how
is that guy not in some sort of
attention at the moment or incitement
like that that's the he orchestrated it
yep I mean
did a whole lot more to get people riled
up than Donald Trump did that's right
well in Donald Trump's life we're going
to be peaceful where the party of Law
and Order don't forget raps is like a go
do it yep and I built a timeline uh
directly after the six and literally the
first breach that happened at the
Capitol it was 19 minutes uh Trump had
19 minutes left in his speech so you
can't really say that Trump was the one
who incited it it was Ray Epps that
literally formed that initial group that
I followed to the Capitol all of the all
of the people that say that Trump
incited Etc that is all garbage like you
can say that Trump didn't do enough to
to quell it and calm them down and at
least I'll say I think that I might
disagree but at least that resembles the
reality that I experienced when people
say he intended to do it he was getting
people riled up the day before and et
cetera et cetera
he did not go there and tell people to
attack the capital he was not telling
people that they needed to go in blah
blah blah blah he was definitely you
know I mean he wanted to be president
still and he was looking for any any
excuse to stand up can you blame him
though no I mean I get it I I get it
there there was there was a lot of
things that he had to be
irritated and and unsatisfied
dissatisfied with about the about the
election and leading up to it I I
absolutely believe that but you know he
didn't it wasn't an Insurrection at all
that's why exactly that's why people how
are you going to oversee government with
no firearms there is no there and and
there was there was never going to be an
a situation where Donald Trump actually
walked away in charge like that wasn't
in the car and how does it make sense is
you're you're just disrupting this
proceeding even if you somehow take over
the capital it's not how the US
government works right like you can take
over a government building you can squat
there nothing is going to come from that
there's still I mean there's checks and
balances everything that is in place to
make it not possible yeah it used to be
used to be that if you took a building
that's where the paperwork was and they
didn't know who was signed up for what
then you ran the show but now it's all
digital well I've always said I've said
this since day one is you know like I've
reported on a lot of a lot of violence
and a lot of things in my career but you
don't walk into one of the most secure
buildings in the the world unarmed
unless you're allowed to and they're on
video I mean it's literally on video
cops saying hey I don't agree with you
but come on in
open the door for me we've seen uh
several acquittals because of it holding
the door so so what happened with uh
Ashley Babbitt's mom
um most recently yeah so she was
actually arrested for jaywalking which
is absolutely absurd uh are you walking
ever since uh you know she actually had
a dream uh come to her I don't I don't
recall how long ago this was I mean
because she was vehemently fighting for
you know Ashley Babin to get her uh
daughter essentially
um Justice in this situation and she had
a dream where her daughter came to her
and said uh you know there's not much
you can do for me but you can advocate
for these j6 prisoners and ever since
then she's flown to DC DC she's been in
DC ever since and she is outside doing
prayer vigils um of the jail every
single night I mean she's out there
advocating for these people and the
Capitol Police have had a bone to pick
with Mickey for a very long time and I
remember the last uh not this most
recent one where she was arrested with
the year before that I was with her
outside the jail and we were the very
last ones there when we're walking home
and you know the uh the Capitol Police
and MPD are literally joking with her
and they're saying hey get in the back
of our car you know we'll take you where
you need to go and knowing full well
that someone within their ranks murdered
her daughter I mean so these people you
know I try not to group all of the
capital the police because there are
some good people within the Capitol
Police Department in but there's a lot
of them that they openly joke about this
and then they targeted Ashley Babbitt's
mother and arrested her for jaywalking
even though you had over four people
right next to her doing the exact same
thing but then they conveniently only
arrested her on January 6th in DC
jaywalking in DC on the anniversary of
her daughter's death
jaywalking jaywalking and Narco tyranny
that's what they call it you guys know
that one yeah it's basically the law is
enforced only against their enemies yeah
that's where we're at she'd be a good
guest we live in anybody that's
advocating to get these people out of
detention unethical unconstitutional
detention you have a right to not be
detained for her husband is Ashley's
husband is absolutely amazing too Aaron
Babbitt that would be someone to have on
the show he's a great guy
it kind of feels like with uh a lot of
the stories that we've gone through and
stories like this
we call it a control demolition
right like the system is intentionally
being destroyed in various ways the
government's been weaponized I mean even
now as we're sitting here laughing about
the IRS being abolished it's another
component of dismantling the machine I'm
sure Luke doesn't care either way I'm
probably excited for it but in other
ways our culture is also being
dismantled that's the dangerous part
we're not we're not raising our kids
properly the kids are being abused
things like that
without proper culture and without uh
proper parenting nothing else matters I
mean it's going to be
it's gonna be apocalyptic I mean the
culture I would say is is majority lost
I mean I'm in Texas I'm a resident Texas
and I'm covering child drag shows uh
every single week I mean so these people
are on video grooming children and
there's no repercussions for what
they're doing simulated sodomy in front
of kids yeah what's the American culture
right now uh twerking seed oils
promoting sodomy promoting uh obesity I
mean you guys saw that picture on
Twitter today where there's those three
models and the one the one on the very
right with the elephant trunks you
literally can't even see her shoes or
with the remainder of them but that's
promoted as healthy mixing cough syrup
with alcohol that's American culture
right now opiates video games yep video
games is a big part of it so one thing
that I've been talking about quite a bit
and I'd love to talk with you Tyler
about it is this book genderqueer
because uh apparently nobody's read it
it's insane apparently numbers right so
uh I've reached out to a handful of
people you'd think would have read it
um prominent critics and uh FairPoint I
didn't read it either what we all knew
in the book was that you've got these
images that are graphic and we're like
okay kids shouldn't be around that and I
think most of us just assume that the
Memoir stuff is immaterial like if
you're talking about your life how you
grew up I don't care don't show the
graphic stuff to kids then as it turns
out actually
the book itself is it's a horror story
of child abuse and so to go back to what
you're saying you're in Texas and
there's child drag shows the fact that
it's even coming to Texas is alarming
then it goes to Florida
I think people need to read this book
and I've been saying this all day
because I really really do mean it and I
want to make sure I I highlight this I
can't show these images no it'll get
taken no no but it's not even it's not
even the images people know for those
that aren't familiar in this book
there's graphic depictions of adult
activities but on the first page let me
see let's go to page number two three
four
here we go okay so right so actually
page one two
it's a it's it's a little boy and girl
peeing in the in the yard outside and
the first part of the story is how her
parents brought her to a farm and had
her and and the neighbor boy just
relieving themselves in the outside
complete neglect they talk about how
they didn't have proper uh you know like
YouTube yeah there's that portion about
where she gets pulled aside by her
teacher in school because she smells so
bad and has I don't know if I can say it
but basically her period blood uh in the
same pad over and over again crumbling
down her leg but you're not allowed to
talk about that's that's marketed in
kids libraries so what this right and
what people uh as we're talking about
this stuff fail to understand is that
when I started so here's what happened I
was going through this because I was
trying to show the Hodge twins the
portion where the author of this book
they're giving to Children is intent
attempting to ingest her own you know
genital fluids and uh you know in order
to find that part I have to I'm like you
know what I haven't actually read read
the book I started reading it and it's a
story about how her mother abused her
had her wearing days or not that even
days old she just says I'll read it she
says I'd often wear the same pet for so
long that dried blood turned to dark
crumbles resembling coffee grounds
where was her mom she's no no wonder she
hates herself she was psychologically
abused and traumatized by her mother and
physically she she's in school and it's
in the book she's like the counselor
pulled me aside saying you smell so bad
people are complaining did your mom not
teach you how to take a bath she didn't
know how to shave her legs you don't got
to shave your legs dude I don't care but
at least the parents could explain to
you why women shave their legs why some
don't you can choose she had no idea she
couldn't read until she was 12. is there
a dad ever mentioned in the book yeah
and and the crazy thing is they're
depicted as like these these
happy-go-lucky hippies like hanging
around and playing the guitar when in
reality I wouldn't be surprised if
they're drug addicts I'm not kidding
like the idea that she couldn't read
until she was 12 to me is indicative of
parents who are on drugs or even take do
basic necessities and take care of
herself enough so she doesn't stink and
gets pulled aside yeah like hygiene dude
I want you I want you the most basic
thing to understand is proper hygiene
right the reason why I think it's so
important to read through the stuff as
we're looking at like the morbid obesity
with the shoes bulging all of these
things that people would say is like
degeneracy or whatever it's like dude it
starts somewhere it starts with kids
being abused and we see it over and over
again people I'm not telling you to buy
the book but you know you can read it
online and it's it's like I want you to
imagine this a 12 year old kid who can't
read
walking around with crusted blood
between their legs smelling like feces
peeing in the yard covered in hair
that's a wild child and then this person
struggles to social to socialize becomes
completely traumatized and hates
themself you wonder why no surprise this
person is coming out and saying I'm
non-binary I don't want to be like
anybody because in the book she talks
about how she's made fun of how she's
embarrassed and it's like well well no
crap she was being a it's like the
parents may have well just kicked her
out in the yard and locked the door
that's what it sounds like they did she
goes to school and everyone's making fun
of her because she smells like crap and
she's got dried pads in her pants
shows that I covered too is I would say
95 to 98 of the time it's single obese
mothers that are bringing their children
to these shows I mean so they can't even
take care of themselves and that's what
I see as a common reoccurrence or
dressing their their you know male boys
up in tutus and dresses I mean and a lot
of my footage I've you know I've
unveiled teachers bringing their
children to this uh talking about the
grooming of their children like it's a
totally okay and acceptable thing I mean
the drag queens literally engage with
these kids on stage say sexual jokes
they do sexual things directly in front
of them and actually involve the
children in it I mean it's a form of
psychological abuse that I've never seen
before I mean this is I don't want to be
covering this stuff but ever since the
Mr misters one really exploded in pride
month uh you know it's like they've
tripled down this community they've
tripled down over and over again and now
I see multiple of them every single week
the most revealing thing about this book
to me is that that graphic image in
question that everybody talks about the
picture of adult activities the main
character the author of this book writes
out it wasn't doing anything for her so
think about this it's a person who's
abused by her parents neglected filthy
uneducated can't read confused about who
she's supposed to be or what life is
like yeah when you when you leave a kid
out in the wilderness and they grow up
they're not going to be able to properly
function she then tries to engage in
we'll just call it Kink and then she's
like hey this actually isn't doing
anything she's clearly confused she
doesn't enjoy what they're telling her
she should enjoy she's completely
desensitized and that's what they do to
a lot of these children at these drag
shows that I go to is they desensitize
kids to sexually explicit content and
simulated sodomy at a young age so then
they grow up and they don't even
understand what they're seeing I mean
I've there's in the Mr misters when the
first one I ever covered the uh there
was a child sitting at the bar he had a
Nintendo DS he had a Rubik's Cube he was
completely uninterested in what was
going on he had two moms with him and
the gay bartender who was serving drinks
over his head literally asked his kids
if this kid if he is gay and he says no
and his mother butts in on behalf of him
says no no no he is gay but he's just
too embarrassed to talk about it you
know it's really interesting I want to
mention this too
I'll say it again you got a kid can't
read dried blood peeing in the yard
covered in hair smelling like feces
and people are making fun of making fun
of her look at but then all of a sudden
she meets the queer straight Alliance
and they're like thank you for being
here we love you and she goes yes this
is who I am exactly no surprise it's it
they're the poor person that wrote that
book has been absolutely psychologically
brutalized their whole life and then
they're put in a position where if they
engage with this activist Group which is
what LGBT essentially is especially when
you're dealing with with queer Theory
and stuff
um they get the affirmations that
they've been dying for they get the love
they get the they they get loved the
confirmation that they need in their
mind it is it is very typical cult
Behavior find someone that is vulnerable
that is dissatisfied that is that is in
a position that really needs help and
then tell them all the P all the reason
that you're unhappy is because of all of
these people it is literally the same
book that every manipulation
manipulative person does and governments
do it you look at what what the Nazis
said you look at what what the Communist
said blame the bourgeoisie blame the
Jews blame the straight people blame the
Christians it's just the same thing and
then think about this once again a kid
who's neglected in all these ways
smelling like crap and then this group
comes and and she explicitly talks about
how she has crushes on boys too like
this is like a normal little girl uh
being abused and then the the qsa says
we're so happy you're here and then
she's smiling and they're like yay we
love you and by the way those people who
made you feel bad are the bad ones
they're the problem and there you go now
all that anger and resentment she felt
it's almost like a kind of sour grapes I
feel bad for because it's like if she
just had someone tell her look girls
shave their legs it's a social custom
you don't have to do it but all the
other girls do so they may make fun of
you if you don't she didn't have that
she writes how she's like I didn't even
understand what was going on why they
were laughing at me I couldn't even read
crazy then they villainized those who
are laughing at her for being on social
and you know that sucks too to be
completely honest she wrote this I I
believe because it was like a memoir she
calls it a memoir about her life and
like expression of her experience but
like I believe the kids in the book are
under 18 that are experiencing the
simulated sex acts so if I wrote a comic
strip of two 14 year olds having sex
they would call that child I mean I
think you're supposed to call it child
porn I don't know if they're underage in
that portion they never say if it's
underage or not or if they indicate that
they're at that point I think she's in
college and she's like working a job or
something and also drawing of of sexual
images gets dicey about the legality
because there's a there's a artistic
yeah there's and there's there's a type
of anime
that pushes the line apparently like so
and there have been like court cases
where they say because it's drawing
Lolly's okay yeah which is creepy and
gross but I mean you know it is what it
is I don't know that that's illegal but
a lot of these books that are being
actually marketed in children's
libraries do have what you know rational
people would call child porn in them I
mean it has depictions of naked little
girls naked little boys engaging in
certain things I mean and exploring
their body and I understand you know
maturation right basic maturation we all
took we all took it um but that's
teaching about STDs teaching about how
to be safe it's not teaching about how
to actually engage in sex I mean I'm old
enough to remember when they used to
tell you to abstain from sex so you
didn't you know contract these STDs or
go through these terrible experiences
and now I mean books like this are being
marketed to children on a daily basis in
almost every single state of the country
thousands of schools she says she's 25
in that oh wow 25 years old in that
particular portion of the book well well
you're right about Lolly porn that's a
big problem of contention on social
media on Twitter though
Elon Musk has been like none of this and
it's legal it's legal in the United
States because you can't prove that it's
a kid even though it looks like a kid
but you know they're drawn just like
children yeah intentionally because it
is I think I consider it a form of
childhood that's if you ever go on like
the the map forums right
um which what we call what is the
pedophile forums I mean they they share
Lolly relentlessly amongst each other
and it's because it's marketed towards a
certain group of people and they know
what they're marketing towards there's
an interesting thing about this too is
when you read that portion it's it's a
very female perspective on sex and it's
funny because the the you know those
individuals writing how they're queer
and all that stuff but I'm like
I think if like as a dude reading that
I'm like yeah that's a woman like I'm
not trying to be a dick or anything I'm
like the thing she's describing about so
you guys remember 50 Shades of Gray and
it was like women Shades of Gray of gray
women loved that book because women and
men experience and stuff very
differently and men are very Visual and
women are very much more imaginative and
that's basically how the book describes
all of this stuff even to the point
where she says she doesn't enjoy any of
it I'm so glad you read it yesterday and
started got that perspective that it's a
kid that was abused that's such an
important part of this it's it's I I I'm
I I can't even begin bro I can't even
begin when I saw this I can't even show
it on camera oh wow yeah oh wow indeed
like you look at this yeah and you're
just like this poor kid man yeah I was
the real person that lived through that
that's so that's that like that is
it's something that I feel like people
that have you know gotten outraged about
that they're outraged at the person for
writing it and it's like it does suck
that they wrote it but remember they're
writing it because they were abused I
don't think it sucks that they wrote it
I think the problem is they're giving it
to kids that's the only problem with
this I I actually think this is really
important because now you can see how
the trauma and abuse leads to this
person being unhappy and depressed and
and talking about how they dread things
and how they fear things and as adults
we need to understand what's causing
these things to happen so we can help
people the problem is they're putting in
front of kids
that's messed up yeah I mean a lot of
this is uh emotional manipulation
there's a reason a lot of Disney movies
start off with either a parent character
or main character dying off in the
beginning because that trauma is very
powerful to ingrain a lot of different
ideas the CIA started to experiment with
certain things especially when they were
starting to do MK Ultra mind control uh
tests on a lot of human beings causing
them trauma fragmenting their
personalities and brains and then
implementing a new one to see how far
they could actually impact someone with
the ideas that they wanted to put inside
of them so I think trauma is a key
element to all of this that we have to
really understand for for how it's being
used here because you lay out the trauma
and then you of course you have the
problem the new course you have the
solution the solution is you got to join
this group this group's going to take
you in it's those people that are bad
those people that are responsible for
all the bad things in this world don't
take personal responsibility just join
the cult everything will be fine and
those ideas are being ingrained into
small children when they're in school
they're being indoctrinated into the
cult into the statist Communist larger
ideology and then they're kind of you
know acting like the way that they are
very uh emotionally triggered
individuals that of course are being
used and manipulated by the state that
is using their trauma Their Fear their
emotions for their own personal gain
yeah trauma is the easiest way to I
would say hypnotize people I mean
because you can use that term yeah I
mean whether it's you know there are
trauma can have good responses there are
good trauma responses but that's very
rare but when you're experiencing Trauma
from such a young age like all these
children that are being exposed to these
shows and to these sexually explicit
content on purpose it's completely
intentional because it fragments their
mind just like you said let's talk about
this uh this healthy at any size they've
got this tweet from Natalie uh
demolition Health in any size is a
complete and total lie even if her shoes
are begging even her shoes are begging
her to stop where are her knees stop
celebrating this forever say I feel
really bad for this woman right here
this uh you can't it's hard to see
because of the way the the crop happens
but uh let me see if we can uh
show those feet geez look man this
person is suffering well they're being
put on a platform like it's a good thing
and this this imagine somebody was
biting their own skin off and people
were clapping for them as they did it
it's like dude we need to help these
people but we're coming to this point in
our society where a large faction of
people just say who cares if it feels
good it's like uh if it makes you happy
then why the hell is it so bad yeah it's
a horrible ethos a lot of things make
you happy drugs can make you happy and
they destroy your life this person
needed an intervention this person
needed someone to say hey
cut the carbs
lower your salt intake all that stuff go
for a walk instead they said
be you
strap these shoes to your feet and bind
them and then we'll put you on a
magazine ad this person's gonna die
young
I looked up I looked up the definition
of fat phobia on Boston Medical
it's absolutely amazing they're like fat
phobia is deeply ingrained in systemic
racism white supremacy and misogyny it's
a typical buzzwords buzzword buzzwords
it's all garbage and lies that that is
all just absolute I have to wonder
though man I have to wonder if there
really is a depopulation agenda then uh
we win in the end like the intention of
the people who want there to be less
people is that these people die instead
of helping them because if it's true and
and these powerful Elites are like
there's too many people well here's one
way to get rid of them I am a human
being I am not a monster I will never
ever approve of that and I mean even
even but even the depopulation agenda
that targets you know people like this
that are morbidly obese it's not like it
just targets them and we're gonna
necessarily win in the end is because
we're still intaking the seed oils we're
still intaking the bugs at this point
we're gonna intake every single aspect
of the depopulation agenda so it's
making us more unhealthy as we go yeah
Tim there is a depopulation agenda and
we're not going to be the winners of it
there's a lot of these individuals that
are literally and figuratively weighing
down not only our health system but our
entire society and when we look at that
we are going to look at the production
yeah but when we look at especially with
how the population is going to crash how
it's already crashing how fertility
rates are going down uh birth rates are
going down dramatically this is going to
have a significant impact on society
that's going to be very devastating
since there's going to be a lot of older
people not a lot of younger people and
that's going to create a lot of economic
and social chaos that's going to be very
difficult to navigate this is what I'm
saying this morbidly obese woman will
die will die young cancer heart attack
something this morbid obesity is bad for
you heart disease when when these people
who are
given the choice
they are told outright you can be happy
eating whatever garbage you want there
are other people who are like nah I'm
going to take the personal
responsibility and improve my health the
people who choose the personal
responsibility I lost 30 pounds are
going to live a lot longer I I want to
ask you a question when you launched
that 30 pounds did you feel like you did
you feel better in your body right man
like within a week of cutting out sugar
it felt like I had lightning surging
through me when I like I've I've
fluctuated weight before and my heaviest
was 177 right and that was when I was I
was puffy and I'd been eating a lot to
put on weight to get muscle and stuff
and then over the you know course of
like six months after I cut down and I
dropped like 10 pounds
dropping 10 pounds of fat I felt like I
had a brand new body and it was just and
I wasn't particularly heavy you know
it's like I'm not a huge guy but 175 was
too heavy for me dropping 10 pounds I
felt great I can't even imagine what
it's like for someone that loses 50 60
pounds it's like you get a whole new
body new skin soup it wasn't even about
losing the weight it was just cutting
out the sugars and all of a sudden
everything was improving yeah my blood
pressure was really high it dropped
really quickly just it's just it's just
crazy and and so these are the choices
you can make
my point ultimately is
no one is is is forcing this person to
stuff uh food in their in their mouths
right and so what is this
[Laughter]
nobody's forcing people to to live on
healthy lives not to exercise and to uh
endanger their lives
the end result mathematically is quite
simple
if you have a hundred people and half of
them are inclined to be morbidly obese
and not exercise sterilize their kid and
abort their kids they eventually cease
to exist if the other half is saying
we're gonna have as many kids as
possible we're going to believe in
family we're going to exercise be
healthy and be responsible they flourish
the end result is obvious yeah but the
problem is when when a sect of humanity
is dying off because it's irrelevant or
or not functionable it will take other
things down with it it's like a flailing
drowning person so you might think once
this ballast is cast off Society will be
better but it's really about how like if
people are we'll see like Mass money
printing to pay for social programs for
people that are severely obese in their
70s and 80s Mass injections of
pharmaceuticals most of most people
don't live that long and and you're
absolutely right there's going to be a
massive burden on the system especially
in the healthcare industry sorry go
ahead well you're just cementing my
point um it could be very very
destructive for people like this to be
let to go which is why it's important
that we call it out when we see it
because it's an addiction I think a lot
of these people are obese because of
sugar addiction or high fructose corn
answer or aspartame addiction or all of
the above combining some new unknown
problem that we're finally seeing you
know with with video and television
obesity yeah I think it's uh phthalates
pcbs so we have a glass bottled water
here at timcast and a variety of
functions of Fashions we have uh the
stuff that we order we do have plastic
water bottles because some people don't
care but uh in the studio we do our own
filtered water we put in glass water
bottles
it's a little things man I have a
feeling that in the future they're going
to start talking about Plastics and in
food the same way we talk about asbestos
yeah oh yeah absolutely well they
already kind of do with them I mean you
there's already concerns about micro
Plastics and stuff like that exactly
it's being found in people's blood in
people's lungs yeah and that's one
aspect of it but also a lot of the food
is also being genetically engineered to
hit the pleasure centers of your brain
but actually have no nutritional value
for you and this is why a lot of people
are talking about organ meat this is why
I've been talking about organ meat
specifically because they do have a lot
uh nutritional dense food that is
actually good for you compared to all
the other fluff and nonsense that is
filled with soy and corn they want you
to believe that red meat is what's going
to lead to uh yeah yeah which is
absolutely crazy or that salt is bad or
that fat is bad when in reality what are
they promoting they're promoting high
fructose corn syrup and Seed oils which
which are absolutely inflammatory your
system doesn't know how to handle and
your system is absolutely hijacked by uh
Bill Gates who wants you to have moves
and individuals that are gamifying this
entire food industry in and also at the
same time believe that there's too many
people in this world that should that
should leave a lot of people questioning
what's going on here as he's now
vaccinating animals yeah and changing
their genetics in order to help the
population where did the seed oil thing
come from this is like a new new fad
that's been taken off well the seed oil
the seed oils have been introduced in
the early 1900s specifically by Crisco
and ever since uh Crisco and other seed
oils heavily processed
um you know inflammatory oils into
exactly essentially it is it is exactly
like engine oil ever since it was
introduced we have seen a skyrocketing
of obesity skyrocketing of heart disease
it used to be rare that people were
obese it used to be rare that the people
used to get heart attacks but ever since
the introduction of seed oils there has
been a correlation with this specific
uptick of people being extremely
unhealthy and dealing with these larger
Health ailmates uh you know health
problems that of course uh now almost
more and more people have every single
day than they ever had before what do
you think about using the government to
like break up monopolies
dig this like the sugar industry has
commercials where they sell sugar to
kids they used to have tobacco
commercials where they would sell
cigarettes to kids or young adults the
government had to say you can't do that
anymore hold on Luke the libertarian
party had a guy on stage talk about
selling heroin to kids
with big Pharma one two you look at the
sugar industry they bought off a lot of
the scientists and regulators and they
made a big war on fat now everything's
fat free and everything's filled with
high fructose corn syrup gee I wonder
what would lead to less harm uh some
crackhead selling crack to a small child
or the government what it's doing right
now let's put those let's put those
let's put those got a better one for you
the food pyramid yeah yeah yeah yeah the
government is super healthy when you so
I was looking at the story about there's
a picture showing a bunch of people in
the 60s and they're all like basically
ripped like not right but they're all
thick just naturally and then it's like
what happened and there's a chart
showing Rising obesity rates around the
late 70s and around the same time the
introduction of the food here aspartame
saying like the food pyramid basically
says eat a ton of bread eat a ton of
grains I cut those things out and my
I've never felt better okay I'll say it
right now and I'll be I'll be brave I
would rather have a crackhead sell crack
to to a baby then the food pyramid as it
is right now because that would lead to
more people at the end of the day I'm
willing to take that official stance
right here right now can I just ask
everybody to imagine a baby walking up
to a crackhead scratching his face
requesting crack from the crowd selling
the crack rock sell it the babies
pulling five dogs out of its diaper and
requesting I mean someone's got to
animate that but I will say while we're
on the topic of health is you know I
used to I smoke cigarettes for a long
time from a very young age I got off of
cigarettes I went to vaping because it's
marketed as like the good alternative
right I would argue that vaping is
honestly worse for you it's wet Vapor
you're coating your lungs in wet vapor
and it's not nicotine that you're really
being addicted to like when I quit
vaping it was the worst thing that I
probably have ever the worst advice I've
ever gotten off of is you're literally
vaping seed oil soybean oil I mean the
most highly addictive things that you're
already consuming on a regular basis in
your diets and you're doing that in your
lungs consistently over and over and
over again I mean so I'm gonna use this
platform to add okay and say if you're
vaping in the audience it's going to
catch a lot of flack I already know just
quit the first four days if you can make
it past the first four days
you won just just get it out you know
what the point of vaping is it's called
douche fluting for for the record
everyone needs to understand that and uh
you know there's there's things you
should look at exactly popcorn lung yeah
vitamin E acetate yeah that was in the
dab carts for a long time I mean that's
when you know Trump I believe is signed
the executive order upping the smoking
age from 18 to 21 is because of the
vitamin E acetate they were making carts
at home and then selling it to children
and people were just popping up a
popcorn long out of sudden see crack or
ingesting seed oil popcorn lung well
well again uh it there's many different
scientific terms on this I want to have
to look it back into this because I was
looking into this when I was douche
fluting myself I was smoking cigarettes
and then I got off cigarettes and I
started uh half douche looting half
smoking cigarettes but I still eating
make you feel worse than cigarettes I I
it's hard to tell because they're all
pretty bad for you nicotine though does
have positive effects of your brain and
small very small doses with the paper
that the government mandates for
cigarettes there's uh anti-flame paper
that the government uh makes sure that
all the big tobacco companies use which
is absolutely horrible for you as well
you're vaping metal particles I just
want to recommend for people
um there's a great book uh the easy way
to quit smoking I tried everything to
quit smoking nothing worked but I read
that book and it actually helped me and
showers stopped it and I stopped cold
turkey and it was very easy the easy way
to quit smoking what's popcorn yeah
there was a there was a two years ago
there was a bit of uh maybe three years
ago at this point it came out the
vitamin E acetate was in the nicotine
Vapes and causing what they call popcorn
lung also known as bronchiolitis
obliterans or obliterative bronchiolitis
that's the word yeah it's a disease that
results in the obstruction of the
smallest Airways of the lungs the
bronchiolus due to inflammation
wow well I mean you got to think if
you're consistently and it's not just
vitamin E acetate either that can cause
this stuff but that was a large
occurrence and that's what they actually
studied is if you're inhaling metal seed
oil soybean oil and Lord I mean a lot of
it's like propylene glycol glycerin into
your lungs on a regular basis more often
than cigarettes because it doesn't make
you stink it actually makes you smell
good A lot of them are fruity flavors
you can hit it discreetly when you're in
restaurants when you're in your house
anything anywhere you want I mean you're
doing this on a regular basis taking
hundreds to thousands of hits a day your
body I mean all things in moderation
your body is not going to have a good
reaction to smoke filled with all these
chemicals and toxins entering you over
and over again can we just bring back
Natural Tobacco and crackers
listen guys guys I smoked cigarettes for
longer than Taylor's been alive and I
disagree strongly cigarettes are the
worst damn things in the world now I'm
not saying that vaping is good but I
don't want people to get the impression
that I'm sitting here saying that
smoking is is not as bad as vaping
without all of it's terrible at least
saying something smoking is the worst
thing in the world I smoke like I said
smoke for almost 30 years it was the
hardest thing to quit I don't I haven't
had a drink I quit drinking five years
ago and it was the easiest thing in the
world to do I for me personally I know
that it's not everybody else I
understand that people have different
situations but for me it was easy
smoking cigarettes if I'm around people
that smoke too much I'm not the guy
that's like oh get that away that's
awful I'm like I'm gonna beat you up and
take them all go away because they're
it's it's such nicotine is such a a mask
you're smoking the fillers the Arsenic
all of the nasty things that they put in
those papers
and it was one of the hardest thing to
quit one of the hardest things that I
mean is you're angry you want to just
strangle somebody and a lot of it is
psychological a lot of this is in your
head a lot of this is subconscious
because of all the propaganda everywhere
that you don't realize but it again
reading that book changed my life made
me quit I don't want to smoke people are
smoking around me I'm like I don't even
care anymore if you haven't read that
book the easy way to quit smoking I
can't recommend it enough what's the
what's the easy way you like you read
the book and it in the book it tells you
hey you could smoke as you're reading
this and then it it it it it breaks down
all the propaganda to why you're smoking
it breaks down all the bull crap it
breaks down all the marketing and all
the lies that could that you convince
yourself that makes you want to smoke
and then you kind of unwind the
propaganda in your head as you're
reading this book as you're smoking and
at the end of the book you're like I
just don't want to smoke what the
easiest thing for me to quit was I
remember I went on a hike and I had just
like went off on a little tour and you
know I used to I used to be very
athletic uh you know in high school and
I used to do bodybuilding I just do the
whole nine yards and I climbed you know
about 20 rocks off this trail and I got
to the top and I felt like my lungs were
going to explode and ever since that day
I didn't hit a vape I just it was like a
almost a switch being flipped into my
head it was like okay this is I can
actually see that it's affecting me now
and it was very very hard I mean the
first week I literally wanted to kill
somebody I mean the anger is incredible
I found that too with cutting addiction
is uh with a purpose like I had gained
weight when I was 23 24s eating a lot of
McDonald's for lunch and drinking a lot
of Pepsi or Coke or whatever and I
gained like 20 pounds for the first time
my life I was 160 and I was like man I
look fat I can't be an actor if I'm fat
I can't so I have to not be fat if you
have a reason it makes things a lot
easier
um did you ever roll your own cigarettes
or not oh uh like just buy tobacco just
pure tobacco I like those I mean I
understand the addictive nature and
obviously the carcinogens involved with
burning anything and inhaling it but
like without the filters which I've
heard have this not didn't have asbestos
in the 50s they had cigarettes that had
asbestos in the filters so imagine what
they don't know how bad is for you now
and that stuff they have fiberglass in
there cut up the inside your lungs
always one stream faster the fiberglass
was that the uh the crack ones or
whatever I think yeah I do think it was
like the camel crushes things like that
so it adds flavor to it but in reality
you're just sucking down glass and it
gets you higher faster and more addicted
quicker because it's getting in your
bloodstream faster well while we're on
the subject of the collapse of
civilization we got this story from the
Daily Mail new graphic reveals extent of
the great resignation how many have quit
their job since 2021 and which
Industries have been hit the hardest I
saw this and it's kind of crazy the
great resignation isn't over yet
November 2022
4.17 million the number of people
quitting their jobs in the U.S
seasonally adjusted
so uh
I don't know people are quitting their
jobs nobody wants to work people are
unhealthy they're doing drugs
is this a it's an opportunity black pill
or opportunity for a new industry there
are workers that want to get jobs
I feel like a lot of this is my
generation too like gen Z is we've been
fed this idea I call them the
participation trophy Generations because
they expect everything handed to them
they expect to be paid 15 to 30 dollars
for flipping burgers at a McDonald's
meanwhile you know someone with a
doctorate is being paid 30 an hour I
mean this is the generation and you're
seeing it with the Millennials and with
Gen Z and a few other Generations is
they don't want to work and they don't
find Value in actually working hard
um well I don't know for sure I I
appreciate that you said that but I
don't know them so I'd have to go Case
by case but I I for sure I believe
they're they're quitting jobs they hate
doesn't mean that they're gonna hate the
next job they get but there's also a lot
of inflation as Ian is saying and
there's also a record amount of of the
dollar being absolutely devalued to the
point where people are like why should I
work when I could barely make ends meet
when I could just get a government check
right so that's also going into the
perspective here and at the same time
when you're giving everyone
participation trophies when you're when
you're hiring and promoting based off
race and based off uh you know sexuality
rather than actual Merit what gives you
the incentive to actually be good at
your job when you know you're only going
to be selected because of the way you
look or what you decide to shove up
inside of you right so I think that or
not shove up inside of you the value of
time is or to shove something inside
someone else have you guys clarify that
like working for hourly is maybe a
defunct method of of payment for uh
employees these days because like I feel
like you can get so much more done per
hour than you used to be able to do
you're thinking about the wrong jobs
though I think for somebody who's got a
specific job like I need you here right
handing bags of food out for three hours
hourly makes sense
you're not going to do it by like for
every bag you hand out you get 10 cents
you know what I mean because man our
wave wage slave sucks do you guys ever
do that I mean pretty much everybody
else let's try that let's do that let's
uh when I open the coffee shop I'll say
for every cup of coffee you hand out
I'll give you a dime
dude you know they'll be upselling that
you want another one you want two cups
you sure your buddy's here but hasn't
had one yet I think the problem is that
I'm making no money
oh not on top of there do it on top of
the salary no I'm saying like if if we
want to if we want to talk about hourly
versus actual sales it's like what what
are you paying a person for it's like
the funny thing about the the left is a
funny meme I saw it said
the left the marxists are like the
profits should all be shared among the
workers and the guy responds and says
then if the company and cruise debt and
loses money then the debt needs to be
split among all workers as well and then
the Marxist gets all angry because they
never talk about that one but let's put
it this way the Marxist view would be
like okay how about this instead of
paying you an hourly wage for you to
sell coffee I'll give you a portion of
the labor you produce like okay so uh I
work to get the cups in the coffee you
work to distribute them I will share
with you a portion of the revenue I
think they'd end up making like
substantially less money doing that like
imagine you're working at a coffee shop
and it's a slow morning it's like well I
made 30 cents today because no one came
in for coffee yeah well too bad that's
you know that's it's equality right I've
been there as a waiter waiting two
dollars and Thirteen Cents an hour plus
tips and some days you'd get three
tables walk out with like 14 bucks yep
yeah that's that's the most criminal
thing to be in the US is like that you
pay waiters like a dollar an hour and
then you say oh well they'll make it in
tips I never understood the food
industry is hell if any of you guys have
ever worked in it it actually is like
being a server is a terrible job it
depends because you can get that good
one where you 250 meals at night and you
get like seven tables that's that's so
rare though
usually you're serving soy slop on
plates to people running around I mean
you have hundreds of people filling and
you have sections cut out for certain
Services you're serving 10 people at a
time being a server you're probably
going to be a server at a place like
Applebee's or like LongHorn Steakhouse
or something along those lines those are
the most probably most most uh
profitable yeah profitable but the most
common restaurants that you that you
that you find and you're not finding
wealthy people going in there dropping a
lot of money people that go to you know
people that go to LongHorn Steakhouse
are not like I'm gonna go out and spend
300 and then tip the you know waiter 100
bucks they're they're gonna go They're
Gonna spend their 150 or whatever for
their family and they're gonna give the
waiter 15 because yeah I've been there
East Side Marios Bo's Tavern list goes
on man I went to so many different
restaurants they're not those places the
predominant
uh you know the predominant restaurants
in the US aren't places where people go
that you know have a lot of money that
they're going for a little treat for
their family you know well especially
now I mean tipping is going down too in
the food industry is because the prices
are going yeah you're the same thing you
would get a few years ago at your
favorite restaurant for ten dollars
you're now spending twenty dollars on so
then you're minimizing your tip as well
I I guess you're supposed to well you're
supposed to not do whatever you want you
don't have to tip if you don't want to
but give them 20 of the bill so if the
the food cost doubles then they'll be
getting double the tip
um but that's discouraging a lot of
people from even eating out now too is
because they don't want they don't have
that money necessarily to tip where's
all the money what happened it went to
the Ukraine are there like just really
rich people that are hoarding their
hundreds of billions offshore where's
all the money well what do you mean
they're just printed like seven four
trillion or six trillion or something
you know big Pharma is creating more
billionaires than any other industry out
there right now and during covid there
was a large transfer of wealth from
wealth transfer in the history right I
think the history of the world yeah uh
where we saw the most of money money go
from everyone to the billionaire class
and the billionaires doubled tripled
their wealth while everyone else was
left holding the bag as of course they
weren't allowed to have private
Enterprise they weren't allowed to have
businesses as the government came in and
said Mom and Pop you got to shut down
Walmart has to be open strip clubs
liquor store you guys can stay open it's
leading me to want to be like workers of
the World Unite let's take our money
back but we all know how that turned out
so we're trying to figure out a
different way like we're trying to find
out a 21st century hammer and sickly
yeah I've got plenty oh you have right
here no thank you well we know are you
sure you want this job we know
I will reign in uh
I think it's funny I mean like you know
you guys are more uh libertarian
anarchists Ian's more uh government yes
liberal elections I'm not being honest
because I think a lot of people are
feeling what I'm feeling the frustration
is building I'm like you know what
popular stuff Rising if that's what it
takes we'll just get a bunch of famous
people to scream it out on days on
Thursday at two and then that's when it
begins I mean you are has never worked
populist no they don't you're right
they've always ended up with worse
governments the only like people say
that America I'm gonna get into a little
rant here people say that the United
States is not a unique country there's
nothing special about the United States
the United States is one of a
vanishingly few countries in the in the
world that had a revolution and came out
better on the other side right like the
revolution that the United States had
when we separated from the British the
United States was a more free country
and then went on to become an even more
free country as we continue to work
towards the ideal set forth in the in
the Bill of Rights in the Constitution
you know what and if people are asking
the question that's Tim playing with the
the gooch sound stick healing energy bar
you know what's appalling to me is is
when we literally overthrew this
government and we I mean we started I
can't say wait but our ancestors and I
mean the founding fathers started you
know America what is America now is we
were actually being prized I mean taxed
decently fairly okay and now you see
what's going on these 87 000 IRS agents
and everything else and it's like where
you know I keep I keep hearing from all
these people that Revolution is in our
blood and it's like where well that's
why I brought this up look at the
Declaration of Independence I mean the
list of grievances was more than just
happened yeah of course you know so I
bring it up because I'm feeling grieved
right now at the system like the mass
redistribution of wealth to the top
these things of people consolidating
wealth how do we revolt against that or
change that without creating a populist
violent populist uprisingly no it
doesn't work legal and local you get in
involved in your local area local
governments local government you get
people that share your opinions and
political views elected to local office
because the people that have the most
effect in your life are the local
politicians you also have the most
opportunity to affect their lives if you
go down to the general store or whatever
and you bump into your selectment or
your mayor or whatever you can give him
the stink eye you know give him dirty
looks and let him know that he's unhappy
and you're going to have the best chance
of having a response from your local
government than you will from state or
federal but then after you're local then
you go for State because the state
governments have an enormous amount of
uh ability to pass laws and legislate
they have all kinds of authority to
legislate there's only a handful of
things that they're prevented from
legislating by the federal government so
to think that we need to overthrow the
federal government is a vast is a
massive error what you need to do is get
James get in touch with James Lindsey
and help get people elected to school
boards right in your local area because
that is how you affect the most
immediate change and it's also peaceful
and it's legal well I I agree with I
mean local is always more important than
Federal I mean my reporting on the drag
stuff I mean the past half a year that
I've been doing it in Texas alone I mean
the GOP is already in Texas Texas GOP
has already made it one of their top
priorities is to basically reword the
coding of the sexual uh basically um
involvement with Children what you can
do in front of children and now the
legislation the new legislative session
is coming around I mean they're talking
about passing laws to ban children from
these sexually explicit shows I mean so
anyone can make a difference reference
on a local level but you just need to
know how to do it I need to do it in an
effective way I'm not so sure the laws
are going to fix that problem though
they're just going to go underground
no no I don't think so either in
Arkansas they're gonna they're trying to
make drag shows adult the same things
like whatever but uh it's already
illegal to perform sex acts simulate sex
acts in front of children in Texas and
they don't do anything about it yeah
well I think it's the way that the the
penal code or I mean I'm not sure I'm
not really well written on law but the
way that it's written is that's what
allows it to happen so the GOP is going
to go in and try and tighten it up I
don't have that much faith in the GOP
obviously for very understandable
reasons I I disagree I mean I'm pretty
sure that if you walked up to a
playground and did what those people did
oh you'd be and you'd be in jail so
there's no difference yeah the issue is
that the cops culturally are unwilling
to enforce well I mean Dallas PD Fresno
I mean Frisco PD all of these places
that I've covered these drag shows in
they know what's going on is wrong but
they're not willing to actually do
anything about it yeah they're terrified
I mean and it's understandable in a lot
of aspects are the same way it's like
someone needs to be the first officer to
make an arrest to go in here and to drag
these drag queens or drag Kings because
they are all men at this point that's
what we should call them did you just
say that cops in Texas are scared crazy
you valday was terrified I am shocked
that police officers in the great state
of Texas are frightened guys
hey you guys aren't backing the blue
enough no
no I think that's the root problem here
I back good ideas
if these officers walked in and they I
mean they dragged these people out I
would be I mean clapping and cheering
jumping up and down with Joy but you
just don't see that no one is actually
willing to be the first person to do
this because they know it's going to
cause a lot of crap for them in the
future which someone needs to stand up
and do it but it's just a matter of who
and when I hear Florida is doing some
actions against those uh kind of dragons
at least they're trying to yeah so
buddy mining New Hampshire is also doing
the same thing he's in the New Hampshire
State Legislature Mike Belcher follow
him on Twitter uh he's uh he's he's got
actual legislation that he's presented
to
keep the kind of woke mind virus stuff
out of
um the law in New Hampshire so but if
people look it's only a matter of time
these laws get overturned get removed if
people don't speak up because I said it
before I'll say it again if there's you
and a leftist and you're like I'm too
scared to speak the leftist is screaming
non-stop the children only hear the
leftist right so that's it you got to
speak up you you hit the nail on the
head a long time ago when you talked
about how the leftists are the ones
that'll make the noise and that's why
they don't get banned from platforms
look at how bad right though right
Wingers are actually organizing things
too that's what I've noticed the past
few years is the only thing that's like
actually been like a successful in
organization of the right has been like
you know like the stop the steal and the
mega the Mega Million marches those are
the really the only things that I've
seen that have like been semi-successful
I mean anytime you go I mean even in
Texas the people you know the Catholics
and everybody that organize against
these drag shows they're severely
outnumbered every single time by local
John Brown Gun Club in antifa and you're
in Texas
yeah
crazy in Texas
yeah everyone talks about how much they
love Texas and I am one not to support
that I mean one it's flat and two there
is more sexual exploitation of children
going on there than I would argue
anywhere in the country that's true in
the Border too the border is out of
control I read a story about some lady
she like she said she walked out of a
bar it was like a post on Reddit I think
and her boyfriend and his two friends
were like 10 feet in front of her a car
creeps up they open the door jump out
grab her and try dragging her in start
screaming the her boyfriend and the guys
run over and grab her pull her out of
the car before they and then they speed
off it's just like well you can just
Street kidnapped women in Texas and then
drive them well and you can literally
walk down I mean like two years ago this
didn't exist really I mean language
barriers in Dallas did not really exist
but now if you go and try and film like
a man on the street video or anything in
Dallas you're going to run into people
that do not even speak English I mean
this is a new thing happening you're
having hundreds of thousands and
millions of people coming over the Texas
border and then instead of actually
deporting them Greg Abbott just wants to
ship them to other states which are
still in our country that's right it's a
nice publicity stunt cool the first few
times you do it but you're still in your
country people people are telling me
well they don't have the right to deport
it's a federal thing they can't Deport
it's a state thing and I'm like so send
them into the country I mean that's
crazy yeah send them farther in where
they can spread out and diversify even
more it's a great idea yeah you think so
Texas should be able to deport
absolutely yeah absolutely I mean you
know the whole Texas sovereignty it's a
load of crap I mean Texas should be able
to deport absolutely anybody that they
want if you're Crossing you know
actually last time I was at the border
and doing some border reporting I mean
there was thousands coming over it was
insane it's something I've never seen
before I crossed the real ground with
these people and I actually was
capturing these people as they were
being processed on video and National
Guard and border patrol pulled their
cars in front and told me that I'm not
able to record because at it was the
request of these migrants I said okay so
the migrants who aren't even citizens
here they have more rights than me as a
member of the press freedom of the press
it doesn't exist like they're right
Trump's mind and this should have said
yes so it's like there's there's a very
big problem going on at the border
specifically in Texas and we're going to
feel it for a very long time all right
uh uh White pillar black belt do you
think we're heading we're going to make
it through this do you think it's going
to get worse I mean I like to say you
know I I like to take a black pill in
the morning and then a white pill at
night before I go to bed that's what I
like to do but everything is going to
get worse before it gets better that's
how it always goes it's always going to
get significantly worse and yeah is
there going to be an upturn I do think
there eventually will be an upturn but
the next few years they're going to get
pretty bad so you're speedballing
basically it's like the crack to the
baby but to me it's kind of like might
as well working out you know you got to
traumatize the muscle and then let it
rest so whether or not we've got to
break it down and then rebuild it yeah
and we're in the breakdown phase right
now yeah
what does it infiltrate destroy and
rebuild yeah the easiest way to destroy
something is from within and that's
exactly what you're seeing right now
across the country yeah true that you
just gotta we got to protect the IRS you
know
you gotta like use your force of will to
manipulate people's emotions to make
them more American like to make them
more Liberty Liberty loving we're in a
battle of wills of spirits why are you
hurting me I haven't been here and I
haven't seen you in like three weeks or
so and now you're harming me
your point is right the but the thing is
Americans and specifically children need
to be taught that America is not an evil
place right that it that a liberal
Society is not inherently bad because
what they're being taught is that a
liberal Society is bad because a liberal
society makes room for racism that's
what they're taught when you when you
hear critical race Theory the critical
part is criticizing the the ex the
existing structures which is our society
and their use race is the means that
they're using to criticize now America
is a very beautiful thing in a beautiful
place but it's the leaders in charge
that's what people need to be taught in
America it's not it's not about the
leaders in charge it's that it's people
need to understand the fun fundamental
ideals that the United States was
founded on and they need to understand
why they are important it is important
to know why property rights matter
important to know why Free Speech
matters these things matter to our
society and without them we do not have
the society that we have grown with so
we're gonna go to super chats if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
the most powerful way to support us and
become a member at timcast.com we're
gonna have that members on the
uncensored show coming up about 11 pm
let's get into these super chats Carlo
Magno TV says I demand an Alex Jones
with your Phil Labonte episode Tim I
just want to say
um okay yes that would be nice but but
you know the last time we had Alex on I
was like we need someone who can kind of
help keep things calm and real things
and we asked Phil to come on
instead of actually doing that I'm like
Phil help me out and Phil goes yeah
yeah just let Alex go completely off it
was so much I was like no what are you
doing so uh so yeah that'd be great we
do it again it'd be fun you're gonna use
the man that screams for a living to
calm down I think you need to rethink
that nobody's about he's like he's a
smart guy you know I'm like he's gonna
he's gonna bring some rationality and
and he just let and I fool you it was
fun though Kyle says Will Chamberlain
was wrong about the holdouts have him
back on to take the L yeah yeah will
come back on I've been thinking about
you a lot man we like will uh it's fun
yeah I think um
man I I'm I'm so impressed with what
Matt Gates Lauren bobert and the rest of
that crew did especially Matt Gates when
he walked in and voted present that's
great I love it incredibly well Gates
has been hired Gates has been changing
the whole dynamic between like talking
to like mainstream press as well and
putting out press statements he's just
been going into normal people's Twitter
spaces and taking questions and Fielding
questions from constituents I mean it's
huge and the mainstream press will sit
in the audience not being allowed to
speak and they'll just be fuming and
then they'll end up writing articles up
about it I wonder at what point that the
congressmen will realize that the people
are there for them and want to work
together like like what Gates is doing
like the more people that realize oh
Twitter spaces communication video chats
well Gates and bobert have done a really
good job at really I mean going that
route and people are they're having
they're being very receptive to it
Cortez too she's great at that well AOC
is great not not necessarily it actually
tapping into her base what her and like
ilhan Omar are greater is like going on
a stream with like Hassan that's highly
edited right pretty much pre-scripted
before somebody that already agrees with
all their ideals it doesn't push back
and they'll go on and or they'll play
video games and you know get asked all
these convenient questions so it seems
and it makes it appear like you know oh
they're actually being available to
their base or AOC will live stream and
sometimes read very selective comments
and it's like did they do a really good
job at that but they're not doing quite
what Gates and bobert are doing is Gates
and bobert are actually allowing
constituents to ask them questions and
you never know if a question could fly
off the handle at any point it could be
a very inconvenient question but they'll
answer it anyways but AOC it's all
scripted all right Ian Bridges says Tim
I like the more segments per day like
the old days are you showing the live
stream like you were last week if you
are I didn't find it I'd have it on when
I'm home during the week thanks so
initially I was like I'll do a live show
in the morning and then record my
segments while I'm live it didn't work
out as I thought it would and so I think
that's probably not the way I'll go but
I started doing three 10 to 50 minute
segments like I used to 6 6 15 and 6 30
at youtube.com timcast news but one of
the things we have kind of you know
getting molded together as a potential 8
to 10 a.m live Morning News hangout kind
of show and maybe maybe we'll feel uh
there for it but we're we're trying to
figure it out we don't know exactly how
we're going to handle it because uh it
has to work but I I think with the new
studio space we're building I can see it
in my mind and I am so excited it's like
we've got this big 40 foot tall building
this big garage door is going to be
sunlight pouring in through that open
door there's going to be skate ramps
everywhere on the first floor there's
this big like what is it I think it's 25
uh 25 by like 60 feet or something like
that we have this big room with a couch
and TV and people are going to be
sitting down and we're gonna have these
cameras rolling I'm really excited for
what we got set up and then someone can
just like skate in sit down and be like
what's going on in this morning show
like oh here's the news and we just hang
out in the mornings that sounds like a
lot of fun and that will lead right into
my first segment at 10 A.M so that's how
that that it's an idea it's an idea I
like that one yeah we're we're really
just once this once the new studio is
done and it looks awesome then we'll
know uh for sure the other thing we have
is uh we have the building for the new
coffee shop skate shop game shop hangout
place and studio and uh it just takes a
it takes a long time to do construction
build one of the biggest challenge we're
facing right now is uh short uh shortage
of supplies so we're trying to get
internet installed at freedomastan and
we're told oh yeah we're ready to
install everything permitted good ready
to go no no supplies available sorry no
cabling no no materials can't do it I'm
like well how do we get internet
well the system seems breaking down
Kevin Brady says Phil took my dog and
married my wife why don't you do that
Phil come on man sounds like something
no it didn't happen
well plausible denim then he lied about
it the wife is actually outside the
studio right now same with the dog I'm
not I'm not married and me and my ex are
not cool so Christina H says why are
chickens so funny because that's because
chickens are funny because they just
have goofy faces and they look at you
and they're all innocent about it yeah
they rip you open if they were like four
times your size right yeah Roberto
Junior would walk up and just rip your
stomach right open and just eat you and
like without even looking at you and
you'd be like we're gonna Deep dive on
the terror bird one day you guys ever
see that thing yeah yeah ten foot trash
Panda says baby steps Luke Rome wasn't
built in a day give it a few years and
there will be a serious push to get rid
of the deep State don't be black pilled
Luke come on
I don't like the room I was saying that
too Rome wasn't built in a day as Roman
patriarch propaganda the Romans man
they're in our minds and there they were
racist genocidal Maniacs but I would
argue that Rome even end are we just the
new Roman Empires it's the Roman
Catholic church now is the Roman Empire
basically Raymond g Stanley Junior says
Taylor I'm a big fan of your hit songbop
there it is what did I say before the
segment someone was gonna say it
that was you sa federali says great
guests again without Taylor I would
still be wrong about what happened to
Ashley Luke don't make Phil lose his
voice the guy has amazing things to say
let him speak kill it one more time like
let's hear that war yeah let's see surge
getting ready to drop the mic
there we go is that coming from your
lower diaphragm Ah that's a for ice
cream actually a fry scream
a certain part of my vocal cords I
engage what they call your false chords
as well as my irregular so you work on
this prevents damage not prevents damage
but it's it's the way to get that raspy
kind of sound too it's like that kind of
that was a a pitched yell and then
there's an another scream that I do
that's purely fried that's more like a
yeah I like it sounds like black metal
and I could do it's a bunch of different
things that you can do with that one too
oh come on
that one I can really draw out really
long you work those chords out is that
how you're able to do that yeah oh yeah
there's there's exercises that you have
to do and normally I would do warm-ups
and stuff like that but you know I'm not
actually performing a whole show so it's
not that big of a deal if I don't do
warm-ups although I'm going to be
talking for regularly I probably will
start doing warm-ups before uh anyway
it'd be good to do on the show the plan
was uh I mean this is gonna be crazy
because the plan was Friday Night Jam
sessions that'd be fun we were talking
about doing it here because we had that
space But we never quite got it set up
with the new space we're actually going
to have a music area and we're talking
about Friday night at the end of the
show because we're all going to be
hanging out just having the camera turn
on and someone could jam out hey you'll
be here I'll be here I like playing
guitar Frank says Tim's earlier segment
on genderqueer reminded me heavily of a
child called it poor kid was so starved
he ate a used diaper
geez man trauma that's how to get you
yes
Faith Mara says got super excited when
you all brought up roller derby last
night unfortunately the roller derby
Community is woke AF just know that you
have at least one roller derby chick fan
love you Tim and crew although we gotta
start our own unwoke roller derby yeah
there's our next idea you're gonna start
a roller rink well we got someone here
who quads you know it's like roller
skates does tricks she's pretty good
so we gotta just you get get more of
that you know yeah I think it's great is
it possible to learn to drop in if
you're over 40 yes yeah all right
absolutely I've never dropped into it
into a half pipe but I think that I want
Lean Forward really hard
it's kind of weird because once you
learn how to drop in I don't know if
like
Lean Forward makes sense to me when
someone says about dropping in because
sometimes I kind of don't lean forward
it's just like if you can control your
core you don't really think about it
depending on the trick I want to do I'll
lean more forward or lean more back you
know I don't know I want to learn how to
skateboard now I mean it's good fun
you're gonna get hurt we'll get you
aboard and on Saturday we'll be we'll be
riding around yeah do some tray flips or
something it was funny someone commented
when I posted it Tim Poole 37 year old
skateboarder and I'm like well I'll be
37 in two months but yes yeah that's it
I guess Tony Hawk's 50 something he said
Tony Hawk still the mankind right is he
using a crutch I saw him in a picture
yeah well he had a surgery or something
you know Tony Hawk broke his femur and
then kept skating and I guess he uh it
was healing and then it disjointed
because he was putting too much pressure
on it skating and then he had to go in
for surgery again you know that's a
bummer Tony dude the voice of the people
come on out man you got any connections
uh probably but uh he's not a very
political guy I don't know yeah he'd
just be chill I don't know if maybe he
can come skate the park once again pop
culture crisis
I mean you basically own independent now
so there you go well we don't own
independence no but you own the logo so
well it's not their logo anymore they
abandoned it it's a t dude so uh I will
say the uh that cross logo I have
ordered 10 boards let's see Tim cast
Sports I don't even know what size they
are they're probably eight inches and uh
we're just gonna get them out they might
be eight and a half I'm not sure
obviously I think it's I think it's
eight and a half yeah cool eight five do
you expect people to to show up and kind
of push back on your skating event how
am I doing an event
I mean here's the thing
if we said if we like got a permitted
thing put up a tent head speakers you
could shut it down anybody could yeah
and it's like oh no what do we do you
can't shut down me just being somewhere
you can tell me I can't be there and
then cause problems and I can back okay
I'll go skate there and then I'll like
walk 20 feet and skate somewhere else
like what are you gonna do yeah you know
what I mean it's like we did a speaking
event at this at this theater and then
they canceled the contract on us civil I
mean they owe us money but antifa
threatened to burn the theater down so I
get it nice people well you know I'm
like we're not doing an event I'm just
gonna be literally standing in an open
space and so if people you know what I
think to happen I think no wacko
leftists will actually show up I think a
bunch of skateboarders might show up
yeah I think a bunch of fans might show
up and it'll just be a fun day in DC and
we'll get to hand out some boards or
something I mean if anything they should
be happy about this event because you're
handing out skateboards you're yeah
we're gonna give away probably like 50
boards yeah yeah let's give it back to
the community 10 a.m guys
no no no no I don't have just right back
but Tim cast boards we've got step on
snack and find out boards and then we
just have regular old Tim cast boards
all the Tim cast sports are eight five
because that's what I ride and then all
the step on snack ones vary in size are
they already gripped or is it just wood
just wood just wood yeah I gotta get
your own grip
um we have grip maybe bring some out but
uh I don't think we have enough to give
out so it's just like you get a board go
find the grip yourself I think it'll be
interesting to see what people do I mean
if there really are a bunch of woke
crazies who are mad at giving out boards
what are they gonna say when we flood DC
with Tim Cascade boards yo I will
literally I'm not kidding I will give
away 1
000 skateboards in the DC area
I will make sure that every kid has a
brand new board to skate on to get more
kids skating it's good marketing get
outside and get some exercise I already
sent like I think I sent like 50 boards
to a local shop that I was like the guys
were we walked into this shop and I'm
you know you never know if you're
walking into a workplace or not and then
you know what I hear so that I walk in
Listen People you gotta understand when
they're coming for your income tax and I
was like oh these guys are gonna be cool
and then they knew who we were and I was
like I'm gonna send you a bunch of
boards feel free to do whatever you want
give them away sell them free we'll just
send them to you we send them out some
boards
I'll do the same thing and then people
are going to be like I'm so annoyed like
they're seeing Tim cast everywhere well
so I I think here's the challenge I've
thought about with this
if I keep giving away free skateboards
as sort of like a marketing promotion
and cultural thing it's gonna start
hurting local skate shops because people
are going to be like I don't know it's
important to give me a free board yeah I
needed like you know I don't need to buy
for myself I don't think a lot of people
are gonna I mean some people will skate
on them but people that know you
probably aren't actually going to skate
on them they're probably hang their deck
up or you know use it in the right
perspective but like if we give out a
thousand boards there's a lot of kids
who need a new boards a lot of parents
are going to be like cool free board so
one thing I might do is just give the
boards for free to shops that are
willing to take them in the area and I
know a few of the shops are super woke
so they probably won't you know but
whatever can you give away just the
board without the wheels yes
then they'll have to go buy wheel the
deck right okay you give out the next
game yeah and everything else that could
actually enhance sales at local shops if
you do that a lot of just boards I mean
at least for the accessories yeah like
for bearings and trucks and everything
maybe what I'll do is at the new Shopper
opening I'll sell the decks for like 10
10 bucks a piece
so like professional grade top industry
level decks but we take a huge loss on
them because it's basically a marketing
budget for us yeah if we get people
riding around on Tim cast up on snack
boards that's generating a lot of
attention for us which is a good thing
and uh we can afford to do it and it can
have a huge impact on the culture so we
subsidize it and then uh all the kids in
the DC area are all gonna be writing the
same Graphics the same company and then
we'll we'll get a skate team we'll pay
our our Riders a salary something no one
else does we will we will hire on five
skaters at a salary to be on the team to
produce clips and segments and rep the
board and all that stuff I think it's
gonna be a blast do you think you'll
eventually go into like manufacturing
trucks and wheels and bindings wheels
wheels are easy yeah but everything's
basically private label trucks are much
more difficult it's really expensive
it's going to be the most expensive part
of the whole board wheels actually maybe
even before decks because wheels are
there's a lot of companies that do
urethane and and I I like super hard
wheels because I like you know when I'm
riding Street I want to be able to slide
around so let's read some more Super
chats
all right John Kirsten Kristen says
Tim you talk about the FBI and the
Whitmore plot look into Brandon caserta
he's great on I know Phil uh on I know
Phil started following him look forward
to seeing you in DC I can I can put you
in contact with Brandon I'm supposed to
do an interview with him but I got a
little bit busy he's one of the people
that was acquitted in the Whitmer
kidnapping he is he is a great guy
he's willing to do interviews too
arthemesia says Adam Schiff looks like
he hates Napster
yeah it does right that's a great
comment
Bravo that's a good one all right the
lion says a fiver for Luke hanging the
Polish power gear behind him oh nice
what does that mean uh it's Jan behovich
he is a Polish UFC fighter that is a
really smart fighter and he was a former
champion and uh he's probably going to
be fighting for the championship uh soon
so uh that's his walkout uh Jersey and
has the Polish eagle on there so
represent Tim Jakes is a 21 year old Air
Force Academy football player dropped
dead today on his way to class no cause
of death at this time only that he
suffered a medical emergency you know
you know these things happen sudden
adult death syndrome
people are spontaneously dying because
of the temperature do you see that story
on Vice that's right oh I got what
that's called did you what's the what's
the word um the wet bulb thing yes
wet bulb I'm gonna pull up the
definition Warrior people get sweaty
then the humidity builds up then they
can't release heat yeah what happens is
the air uh is evaporating off of them at
such a pace that they're not actually
cooling down as it's happening so they
end up overheating wow ice skating and
uh I was skating in Phoenix once I was a
Tempe and it was like 110 degrees but I
felt totally fine and I wasn't sweaty
because the sweat evaporated so fast
yeah that you don't feel the sweat on
you and it's cooling you down but you
dehydrate super quick yeah it's crazy
David Scott says on the parks department
that is public land owned by the people
and we only have access to a small
portion of it and only for the uses they
deem acceptable
sounds like something a communist would
say
I think he's agreeing with you though I
think he's complaining that it's
supposed to be our land but they're
keeping us off of it you don't even you
can't escape in most Parks the worst
thing is like hey there's a big
beautiful Park you show up you're at the
gate and then some status some communist
comes out of his little little toilet
Booth he's like do you have a
reservation I need a reservation to be
in the park are you kidding me I that it
is so infuriating we were in what where
were we uh Austin we went to that
amazing Park we were supposed to go on
this amazing hike we showed up at the
gate what did they say oh yeah so we're
full they're full I'm like what there's
a capacity there's a capacity being in
nature all right squid bugs Anonymous
says Tim I'm one of the four percent
that voted to keep the IRS just kidding
I'm an end cap that doesn't believe in
voting Luke you say you're an anarchist
and you keep advocating for choosing
your next slave driver no slaves no
Masters
I don't think I ever advocated for you
know a slave driver name me a slave
driver advocated for it I didn't
advocate for I said be skeptical of them
uh just like I did everybody else but as
as I compared politicians before I said
politicians are all buttholes some of
them are more stinky buttholes than
others but they're at the end of the day
they all have crap that comes out of
them so uh be critical of everybody and
I disagree with you bro Michael justice
has Tim's skateboard event is a psyop to
flush out his swatters Tim cast secret
service will be waiting and watching
Love from Uber Mike in Saint Pete
Florida it's not an event
there's no schedule there's no plan I'm
going to arrive at 10 and I'm going to
skate that's it it's all that's
happening oh and Phil will be there and
he'll play guitar or or sing or maybe
both and then uh what walk crew will be
there I don't know exactly who's coming
from here and we'll uh we'll hang out
and have a good time and it'll be fun
there you go there I think there I think
we'll have some Bladers some scooters uh
you know some some skateboarders
it'd be fun
Nathan C says let's not forget that
Trump knew he didn't call for an
Insurrection that they are accused of
following yet he did nothing to pardon
the political prisoners who are
wrongfully accused he set him up
just because Trump didn't try to commit
an extra an Insurrection doesn't make
Trump good
hmm I mean well he could he should have
pardoned people yeah he should have got
these people have been locked up for
like two years without without charge
but they neutered him right after the
six they used the six to absolutely
neuter him I mean after that he there
was no Trump left afterwards there's no
Trump left even right now yeah I mean
right now it's actually kind of pathetic
great nft there's a great nfts
that's true
it made a lot of money some say the best
nfts Mike Hillier says Tim your review
of genderqueer is similar to where toxic
masculinity came from the one that came
up with it was a closeted trans woman
interesting
toxic masculinity that's a book I have
no idea
Let's uh let's see becoming ungovernable
says pissing outside is one of the
finest feelings in the world what's
wrong with emptying your bladder how God
intended what I'm basically saying is
you have this little kid who's smelling
like feces peeing in the yard can't read
and has dried crusted blood stuck in her
pants all of those things together say
severe neglect and child abuse right
yeah you don't wanna it's a girl too you
know yeah I was gonna say peeing outside
as a man that's nice but peeing outside
is a woman let alone a little girl over
and over again there's something wrong
with that yeah that's great she couldn't
read until she was 12. like right there
it's like were her parents on drugs
seriously I'm sure yeah why Why move out
to the middle of nowhere and then
neglect your kids just neglecting their
kid yup ignoring the kid it's like you
ever see Matilda the parents just like
we didn't want it it's in the room you
know
yeah that's a sad story it's different
if you have the ability to go pee
outside versus you know being forced to
right just the idea that the counselor
was like you smell really bad and people
are complaining and she's like I'm all
embarrassed now it's like did your mom
not tell you smell bad right did you not
have any family members to be like hey
you need to clean yourself yeah no she
was just scuzzy and messed up and
couldn't read
like this that's that's a developmental
this well it's not development it's what
what would you call that I mean the
average kid learns to read at six years
old she was twice the age of the average
person who learns to read and she
couldn't read what were her parents
doing to her well I'm surprised that I
mean I don't know how long she went to
public school or anything prior to that
but I'm surprised someone hadn't stepped
in earlier than that I mean all the
signs of abuse were there yeah but it
just I mean the counselor realized she
was smelling like crap should have been
like is everything okay at home not
being able to read I mean up until the
point of where you're 12. that should
have been a big sign especially in
school like yeah and I remember in class
you'd have those the teacher would call
on that kid and then they'd be terrible
at reading right but there's a big
difference from being terrible at
reading and having a low efficiency
score to literally not being able to
read well I'm not surprised the schools
didn't do anything I don't think the
schools work but imagine a a 12 year old
kid who smells like crap with crusted
blood in their pants who can't read and
is peeing in the yard is at school
you're going to be like something's
wrong with this kid yeah like where was
where was Child Protective Services is
everything okay do you want a gender
reassignment surgery
they didn't do it like that but like you
get this person who's just so dejected
and angry at everybody who they're it's
like imagine walking in a room no matter
what you say you're wrong and you feel
bad and everyone's laughing at you and
then all of a sudden someone comes up to
you and says I think you're right you're
valid yeah all of a sudden you feel good
all right let's uh let's grab some more
Super chats where are we at
let's see someone else mentioned the 20
21 year old Air Force Cadet who dropped
wow
what is this one uh JoJo Aziza salutes
to Gunners Collective on YouTube
not familiar very cool
Mr grizzly bear says hey Luke what is
your opinion on the show Parks and Rec
I actually I watched it a few years ago
I enjoyed it uh Ron Swanson's an awesome
actor a communist and uh yeah he's like
he's like a self-hating communist it's
it's awesome to see in real life he's an
actual communist yes he is he's a
horrible uh like well yeah I'm not gonna
get into it but the the actor he plays
is uh you know somewhat of a of a
Pioneer I thought it's uh what's his
name's best work
what is his name Guardians he's round
Swanson no no the other guy Chris Brown
Chris Pratt it's kind of a joke he's
good at that dude he's so good
Kim mccersey says Tim you spoke earlier
about your separation from sugar my son
works nights and he doesn't feel right
until 12 a.m asked him how uh how long
by the way 12 a.m in his last soda he
said that's an excellent question
interesting yeah Benjamin RC says I lost
110 pounds and kicked diabetes in 2022
by eating right hell yes dude epic hell
yeah man that's the way to do it yeah
but there's a common misconception that
you can't really get rid of diabetes
either but I've seen I mean I know
multiple it depends on the type yeah it
depends on the type of course but I know
multiple people that have literally
conquered it and then now they look
absolutely amazing type 2 diabetes for
sure there's even evidence that people
with type 1 diabetes can keep there's
some symptoms Wonder like under control
with diet yeah one is like your pancreas
is just done and one is it's overloading
and can't handle your horrible eating
correct yeah
David Neeve says working in the ER the
last 11 years the patients are getting
younger and sicker nurses have less
skills hard keeping up with sick
unhealthy people
interesting
Shane Mann says last night you mentioned
waking up during surgery I did that when
I was five they were working on my heart
I rose up saw all red in my chest pushed
back down and they hit the sauce I was
out in 10 to 15 seconds yikes man that's
a memory yeah
corn Bob says abolished the parks
department thank you
but who will run the parks nobody nature
Grandpa's play says last time I was on a
skateboard Sid Vicious was alive and
part of the Sex Pistols Tim there will
be a time when skateboarding is
something you can no longer do I
disagree I've seen those videos of like
70 year old dudes riding around on
skateboards then you just got a skid on
Mars less gravity that's right you're
gonna fly yep I'm just waiting for them
to fill uh skate parks with sand again
oh yeah oh man that was very effective
Liam black says Hey guys started
listening because of Phil still don't
quite understand all the topics you
cover here but I'm learning so much
cheers all hi Liam Phil's introducing
people into the world of politics
very good how much did you pay her to
say that I didn't pay him anything
become the automator says love the show
I'm starting a supply chain and
automation course tomorrow night learn
how to automate your jobs instead of
being automated very very cool all right
everybody if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to the channel share the show
with your friends become a member at
timcast.com go to timcast.com click join
us we're gonna have a members only
uncensored show coming up for you in
about one hour we have a huge library of
this content that you can browse through
from you know going back several years
and with your support we're gonna be
setting up coffee shops physical
locations creating new shows creating
music starting skate companies and
really going after the culture War you
can follow the show at timcastirl you
can follow me personally at timcast
Taylor do you want to shout anything out
Taylor USA on Twitter that's where you
guys can find me it's where I do most of
my work is at
t-a-y-l-e-r-usa not or it's spelled the
right way but Taylor USA and thanks for
having me on Tim right on uh I am Phil
that remains on Twitter uh you can check
out the band All That Remains all over
the Internet and uh get used to my face
I'm gonna be around here we got him well
thank you guys for coming this is a
great sausage fest and uh you know I
might be leaving but my YouTube channel
is not and it is youtube.com forward
slash we are change I did a video today
about the world economic forum and Davos
agenda being leaked I did a very
interesting video on that check it out
right now on youtube.com forward slash
we are change Polish sausage
or whatever you're into and Patrol your
chakras take care of yourself and your
vibration
if we combine all of the Shocker things
can we summon Captain Planet yeah I
gotta get all eight of them on you at
the same time with eight that was UN
propaganda okay so uh this is the butt
one yeah you got the butt one so you got
to put it in your butt oh it goes I'm
serious that's the good one if you don't
put it in your Gucci
[Music]
shout out to Becky Crossland what's up
dude shout out Becky thanks Becky it's a
hit what is the I feel supposed to do
I feel I don't know it says on there
with a number and whatever number it is
the bottom chakra is one up to seven you
got the sacral the sacrum is what is
that um
oh okay that's why it's shaped like that
here yeah
sacrum is right above the wiener the
wiener yeah is it really yeah and then
the root is right under the wiener yeah
and Tim has the root he has the butt one
yeah right between your legs just
straight up
which one do you have um
you gotta get a work right now do you
really have to throw one I do yeah oh
wow I should put it right on the Adam's
apple I have yeah war cry fell war cry
oh child and see if we can do this you
can pull your Adam's Apple down a little
bit and it like drains fluid out of your
head
yeah
get yourself some vibrating chakra
tuning Forks if you want to they're on
Amazon and elsewhere I'm sure search
what's happening Brother yo what an
interesting episode
um yeah I'll be in the chat I'll be in
the comments rather not the chat I read
the chat all the time but I'll see in
the comments probably have a lot to say
we're gonna enjoy the tuning Forks in
the next episode right all right
everybody we will see you all over at
timcast.com thanks for hanging out
cheers